MORNING GO WELCOME TO THE
DIRECTLY SCHEDULED VISIT
PROFESSIONS BEING THE CHAIR
NOTICES PRESENCE OF A FELLOW
REPUBLICAN MEMBER.
AND WE HAVE THREE BILLS THAT IN
PLACE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
FILE. FIFTEEN AND FILE AND WHERE.
NUMBER SIXTEEN AND WE WILL TAKE
THAT UP ONCE A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED A WE ARE CURRENTLY
ABSENT.
A QUORUM BUT WE WILL BEGIN WITH.
THE FILE BUT WE SEE.
AS EAGER AS CAN BE OUR FILE ITEM
NUMBER --
THREE S. B. EIGHT TWENTY NINE BY.
I'M SORRY OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS S. B. NINE ZERO
FOUR BY SENATOR MCCASKEY.
AND MYSELF WE WELCOME. TWENTY
FOR TELL OUR LOWER COMPANIES TO
CONTINUE TO PROFESSIONALLY
ORGANIZES LIMITED LIABILITY
COMPANIES AYE URGING AYE VOTE I
HAVE ONE MISTER SMITH IS HERE.
TO SUPPORT THAT PROPOSITION.
TRANSMETA CALIFORNIA ALARM
ASSOCIATION --
SPONSORS OF THE BILL WE
APPRECIATE AND I VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING THAN ANYONE SUSPICION TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEEM NO --
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME SENATOR BY CASSIE
DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE YES I'D
PREVIOUSLY AUTHORED AB OR NO S.
B. ONE SEVEN SEVEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND THIS SIMPLY EXTENDS
THAT.
THAT DATE AYE AYE WHEN YOU DO
HAVE A QUORUM MY URCHIN MOTION
AND A SECOND AND THEN I FELT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
CASKEY
[inaudible]
YEAH
WE
BOB
[inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible] ZERO REALLY
[inaudible]
ALL OF
WE QUICKLY.
DAY ONE A DAY.
AND THIS IS [inaudible]
RYAN RYAN.
A STERN WARNING [inaudible]
USING
.
THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT IS
ABOUT APPROXIMATELY NINE
EIGHTEEN M. AND WE'RE STILL
WAITING FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
SENATORS.
ALSO FOR SANDERS IF YOU ARE
LISTENING A WILL CLOSE OUR
HEARING IN FIVE MINUTES IF WE DO
NOT SEE ANY SENATORS ARRIVE SO A
PLEASED TO SHOW UP IN A TIMELY
FASHION THANK YOU
OKAY THAT
SEEKS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
S. B. THIRTEEN OH FIVE BY
SENATOR GLAZIER CENTER GLAZIER
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
HE KINDLY COME UP TO THE PODIUM
AND PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
AND AGAIN WE'RE ACTING CURRENTLY
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
LIKING CORN [inaudible]
WELCOME.
BUT THANK YOU CARILLO. FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THIS MORNING AND I I I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS BILL
THAT DEALS WITH THAT EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES FOR DOGS AND
CATS.
IT MAY SURPRISE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BUT ABOUT FORTY
THOUSAND PETS DIE.
IN HOUSE FIRES IN THE UNITED
STATES EVERY YEAR.
I AND I THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
FIRST RESPONDERS TO PROVIDE.
BASIC FIRST AID ANIMALS ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS AT THE SCENE OF
AN EMERGENCY PRIOR TO TRANSFER
IN THE ANIMAL TO A VETERINARY
CARE FACILITY.
IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL PROTECTS
FIRST RESPONDERS BY MAKING
EXPLICIT.
THAT THEY ARE NOT LIABLE FOR
CIVIL DAMAGES OR SUBJECT TO
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION OR
PROFESSIONAL DISCIPLINARY ACTION
FOR ADMINISTERING BASIC FIRST
DAY.
MANY OTHER STATES HAVE ADOPTED
SIMILAR LAWS.
A COLORADO WAS THE FIRST TO PASS
SUCH A MEASURE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FOLLOWED BY OKLAHOMA IN
ALL TWENTY TWO STATES NOW ALLOW
FIRST RESPONDERS TO PROVIDE.
AID ANIMALS WITHOUT FEAR.
OF PROSECUTION.
BUT MANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MAY BE AWARE THAT.
I WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN WAS FIRST
ELECTED THAT I WAS ON HIS STAFF.
I AND WAS --
INVOLVED IN THE CARE OF SUTTER
BROWN WHO WAS THE FIRST DOG AT
THE TIME HE HAS SINCE PASSED
AWAY HE WAS A GREAT AMBASSADOR --
AND GREAT ADVOCATE FOR ANIMAL
WELFARE --
WE UP TO SPEED IN MANY EVENTS TO
HELP [inaudible]
APORTA.
ANIMALS IN A VARIETY OF WAYS AND
IT IS FOR THOSE REASONS THAT I I
THOUGHT IN MEMORY OF SUTTER THAT
IT WOULD BE A NICE THING TO DO I
ON THIS MEASURE THAT HE WAS SO
INVOLVED IN ANIMAL WELFARE.
I TODAY I'M JOINED BY BY MY
CONSTITUENTS SHAKER WHO IS A
VETERINARIAN WITH THIRTY FIVE
YEARS EXPERIENCE IN THE TRI
VALLEY.
ABROAD AS THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL
AND THE DANIEL HARDING OR THE
BATTALION CHIEF IN THE UC DAVIS
FIRE DEPARTMENTS [inaudible]
AND I HAPPY TO HEAR THEIR
TESTIMONY IF IT PLEASES THE
CHAIR.
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE.
I I AM OF AN AMERICAN PRIVATE
PRACTICE FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
[inaudible]
HERE'S ON NO NORMAL FIRE JUST.
HE LIKE I KNOW.
BOND VERY WELL I ALSO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE CAPABLE OF ADMINISTERING
BASIC FIRST AID AND THE VAST
MAJORITY WANT TO TREAT ANIMALS
AT EMERGENCY SCENES --
I ALSO KNOW THAT --
PROFESSIONAL VENIER CARE WILL
RARELY BE AVAILABLE AT AN
EMERGENCY SCENE --
THIS BILL DOES ALLOW FOR FIRE
DSTRICTS TO OPT OUT IT'S
VOLUNTARY --
I'D I KNOW THAT MY BOARD --
ARE OF COMMAND STAFF ALL OF OUR
CERTAINLY ALL OF THE THE UNION
BOARD -- ARE
CERTAIN IN FAVOR OF SB THIRTEEN
OH FIVE I WOULD BE SITTING HERE
IF THEY WEREN'T IN FAVOR OF IT --
AND I'D JUST LIKE TO CONTINUE
WITH ADJUSTING A QUICK
ILLUSTRATION HERE --
WHAT ARE OUR CREWS GO THROUGH IN
AND WE HAD A RECENT HOUSE
STRUCTURE FIRE --
BASED SAY THAT MOST OF THE
STRUCTURE OF BUT THEY COULD NOT
SEE THE DOG THAT WAS TRAPPED
INSIDE.
AND A HOMEOWNERS IN THIS CASE
LOSS TO SIGNIFICANT PART OF
THEIR HOME --
BUT THEY WERE MOST DISTRAUGHT
ABOUT THE LOSS OF THEIR BELOVED
LABRADOR RETRIEVER.
HER NAME WAS VIOLENT --
THE SEASON FIREFIGHTERS --
DID THEIR BEST --
BUT IS INCONCEIVABLE THAT THEY
WOULD NOT AT LEAST TRY TO SAY
VIOLENT.
AND NOT THE LEGAL THING FOR THEM
TO DO AT THIS POINT AT THIS
STAGE --
WOULD HAVE BEEN TO REMOVE VIOLET
FROM THE STRUCTURE AND
TRANSPORTED TO A VETERINARIAN --
WITHOUT WITHOUT ANY BASIC FOR
STATE [inaudible]
I VIOLET DIDN'T SURVIVE THIS
INCIDENT BUT OUR ONLY SHOT AT
SURVIVAL WAS LIFESAVING FIRST
AID ON SCENE.
EVEN A FIVE TO TEN MINUTE
TRANSPORT --
WOULD HAVE DIRECT DRAMATICALLY
REDUCED TO ANY ANY CHANCE OF
SURVIVAL.
AB VIOLENT BEEN THE PERSON --
IT'S JUST NOT PROVIDING BASIC
FOR STATE WOULD BE INCONCEIVABLE
AND AND I BELIEVE THAT OUR PETS
ARE TOO IMPORTANT TO NOT.
ALSO GIVE THEM THE BEST SHOT IT
SURVIVING AN EMERGENCY AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTEEN OH FIVE YOU VERY MUCH.
MORNING --
MY NAME IS THAT HARD JEREMIAH
TWENTY YEAR VETERAN THE FIRE
SERVICE IN ASSISTANT CHIEF WITH
UC DAVIS OUR APARTMENT.
I CAME TO MY ATTENTION LAST YEAR
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION OF OCT
INDEPENDENCE BY MERGERS FUNDERS
WAS ILLEGAL IN CALIFORNIA.
HOW THE PRACTICE IS COMMON IN MY
FIELD AND OCCURS ON A REGULAR
BASIS NO SURPRISE TO ME THAT
THAT WAS NOT?
ALLOWED.
AND ANIMAL SUPPORT GROUPS OF
YOUNG FUNDRAISING PLACED PET
SIZE AUCTION ADMINISTRATION
MASKS ON FIRE ENGINES AND MANY
CITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
INCLUDING RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO --
IN THIS IS A BIG SURPRISE ME
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ILLEGAL.
ANIMALS CAN EASILY BECOME
TRAPPED IN INJURED HOMES WHEN
THEY CATCH ON FIRE AND
FIREFIGHTERS ARE OFTEN ABLE TO
RESCUE THE ANIMALS FROM THESE
FIRES.
AND AND THEN WE WANT TO DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO HELP SAVE
THEM.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THAT WE HAVE
THE ENDING AND AN EVIL CHOICE TO
EITHER BREAK THE LAW ON SAY THE
AM OR LET THE AND HOPE TO
ACTUALLY DIE.
I WAS FACED WITH THIS EXACT
CHOICE THIS PAST YEAR AT A FIRE
FIVE CATS WERE TRAPPED IN A
SMOKY HOUSE FIRE AND WERE
STRUGGLING TO BREATHE.
NOT GOING TO LET THE ANIMAL
SUFFERED WE ADMINISTERED OXYGEN
WITH THE SAME EQUIPMENT CARRIED
ON MOST FIRE ENGINES ACROSS THE
STATE WERE ABLE TO TREAT THE
CATS AND SOME ON THE WAY TO SEE
ABOUT.
FIREFIGHTERS SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
RISK THEIR MEDICAL
CERTIFICATIONS A POTENTIAL LEGAL
PENALTIES TO SAVE THE LIVES OF
INNOCENT ANIMALS AND I ASK THAT
YOU HELP US FIX THIS PROBLEM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
APPRECIATE CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAME AND AFFILIATION
BICU WISH TO DO SO.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE DILLON
REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA
THE SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY AND
BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS AND THAT
LIKE SENATOR GLAZER AYE TO BE
SPENT MANY YEARS I'M.
ADVOCATING TIRELESSLY FOR
ANIMALS ALONG WITH SUTTER BROWN
AND I THINK THIS BILL IS A HEART
FELL IN FITTING TRIBUTE TO HIS
SERVICE THANK YOU.
HOWEVER MANY WITH WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SUCH A COMPASSIONATE
LEGISLATION ALSO A SPONSOR OF
THE PET LOVERS LICENSE PLATE.
AND THE DAY THAT WE ACTUALLY
LAUNCH THE LICENSE PLATE.
FAIR NEUTER SERVICES I'M SUTTER
WAS THERE AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT WE LIKE MANY
OTHERS I'M REALLY APPRECIATE HIS
ADVOCACY IN WORK AND HELPING US
FROM OUT THE PET LOVERS LICENSE
PLATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SINGLE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISH MISS
BEGINS FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
ASSEMBLY ONE BAKER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER PLEASE BE CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU DR KERR FOR
BRINGING THIS --
FORWARD AND BATTALION CHIEF FROM
UC DAVIS AS WELL AS WE'VE WE
VISITED WITH OUR MUTUAL
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR FIRST
RESPONDER SHE SAID WE WANT TO
HELP.
AND IT PUTS OUR LICENSE AT RISK
AND THEY HAVE THE FAMILIES RIGHT
THERE WITH THEM AND THEY'RE
UNABLE TO DO IT OR THEY THEY
THEY GO FOR IT --
AND SO THIS MAKES COMPLETE SENSE --
I KNOW THERE'S A MENTION OF A
DOG HERE WELL PRO CANNOT.
SIT THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT OF
BUT I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR A GOOD LEGISLATION AND ABOUT
WHEN WE GET A QUORUM OF THE
PLEASED TO MOVE IT THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LITTLE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM I TO
APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD --
AYE A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO --
A IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT I
RECEIVED A PANICKY CALL FROM A
NEIGHBOR OF THE OF MINE.
ABOUT HER.
CAT WAS IN DISTRESS.
I I I I I I I RAN OVER SHE HAD A
VETERINARIAN ON THE ON THE LINE
WHO SAID HERE'S HOW YOU COULD
ADMINISTER CPR TO THIS CAT I'D
NEVER HEARD OF SUCH A THING --
AND BUT I NOW KNOW THAT --
THERE ARE.
A NUMBER OF FOUR STEPS CAN BE
TAKEN TO A SAVE THE LIFE OF A
PET WHO IS IN DISTRESS.
ON HAVE A SON WHO IS A AT NEW
FIREFIGHTER WHO I'M QUITE
CERTAIN HIS --
GOING TO WELCOME OF THE ABILITY
TO ADD THIS TO THE MANY SKILLS
THAT -- THAT
OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHER
EMERGENCY PERSONNEL UP POSSESS
SOME VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
OF AND ON THE WOULD APPRECIATE
BEING THERE BECAUSE HER FATHER
THAT STILL A POSSIBILITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMUNITIES AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE SENATOR GLAZER DO
WISH TO CLOSE.
THAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD SAY THAT.
AT 68% OF HOUSEHOLDS IN AMERICA
HAVE A PET A CAT AND A DOG --
LIKE EIGHTY MILLION HOUSEHOLDS.
AND ON BEHALF OF KITTY WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA IS DODD
KITTY.
I ASSEMBLYMAN MULLINS DOG
SUNSHINE ITSELF IN THE GRAYSON
STOCK SHASTA.
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR AND I VOTE AND JACKSON OKAY --
AT MISS CHAIRMAN I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THAT I KNOW SOME
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED
I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO ACCEPT
ALL OF THEM.
I'D CERTAINLY WOULD PREFER TO TO
KEEP ONE INTO BUT I'LL LEAVE
THAT TO YOUR DISCRETION OF
COURSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
GLAZER THIS DOES ENJOY AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION WITH ALL THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT SAYS
REFLECTING ANALYSIS SO SO SHOULD
YOU BE.
AMENABLE TO THAT WE WOULD HAVE A
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED SENIOR
MOVE FORWARD.
GREAT THANK YOU GREAT
INFORMATION SO WE WILL TAKE UP
THAT -- VOTE --
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM?
OKAY VERY GOOD.
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ENERGY LATER THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NUMBER.
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
WHICH IS SP THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE.
SOME OF OUR WELCOME.
AND CAN ALLOW UP TO A TWO
MINUTES FOR A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN TO UP TO TWO MINUTES
AWARENESS IS AND OBSESSIONS AND
ACQUIRE WEALTH.
TAKE A MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF OF
THE DILIGENT WORK ON THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION.
THAT REALLY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON ADDRESSING THE
NEED FOR INCREASING ACCESS I
CARE AND WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BY THE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION.
A LEADING IN TODAY'S HEARING
THERE HERE PRESENTING A
CONSENSUAL GROUP HUG --
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
TO REDUCE THE TOTAL A CAP ON
OFFICES TO ELEVEN AND CLARIFY
THAT THE CAP APPLIES TO SINGLE
OPTOMETRISTS IN GROUP PRACTICES.
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE EYE CARE
INDUSTRY MISTER CHAIR I HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING SOLUTIONS DO
MODERNIZE PROTOCOLS ESPECIALLY
WITH SMALLER PRACTICES TO MAKE
THEM MORE COMPETITIVE WITH LARGE
CORPORATIONS FOR DECADES.
THE CURRENT BRANCH OFFICE OF
LIMITATIONS LIVE IS ANTIQUATED
QUITE CANDIDLY THE LIES BEEN
UPDATED SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE IN CALIFORNIA HAS CHANGE
INCREDIBLY SINCE THEN.
I'M GONNA AYE SPEED THIS UP
MISTER CHAIRMAN TO SAY THAT S.
B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX WILL
MODERNIZE THE EYECARE INDUSTRY
FOR OPTOMETRIST ON BUSINESSES BY
ELIMINATING THIS OUTDATED
REQUIREMENT.
A AND THAT PREVENTS THEM FROM
OWNING MORE THAN TWO OFFICES
WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO --
IS THE NEW CAP WOULD BE RAISED
TO ELEVEN THE BIRTH OF CORPORATE
AYE CHARIS PLACE FAMILY OWNED UP
TO OPTOMETRIC PRACTICES AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE.
LARGE OPTOMETRIC CORPORATIONS OF
QUESTION ON THE POTS BECAUSE
THEY FOUND WAYS TO OPEN IN
UNLIMITED NUMBER OF STORES TO BE
ABLE TO SELL THOSE EYEGLASSES
AND I CARE. TO ADD INSULT TO
INJURY MEDICAL DOCTORS AND
DENTISTS CHIROPRACTORS THEY CAN
EVEN HIGHER AN OPTOMETRIST IN
THEIR OWN PRACTICE TO OFFER
OPTOMETRIC SERVICES WITHOUT
BEING SUBJECT TO THE BRANCH
OFFICE LAW.
A SB THIRTY NI SIX WILL RESTORE
ELEVEN PLANE LEVEL PRINT PLAYING
FIELD -- IN
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY I'D TODD KAREN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY IN THE MAN THE MYTH
THE LEGEND TO MY LEFT DURING THE
KILL.
WITH THE OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP TO TWO
MINUTES IN TOTAL PLEASE PRESENT
DIFFERENT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MIKHAIL
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION.
WELL WHEN THIS BRANCH OFFICE LAW
WAS WRITTEN IN NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN THEY WERE FOURTEEN POINT
TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE WERE A LAND OF SMALL CITIES
SEPARATED BY HUGE AGRICULTURAL
SWATHS.
OBVIOUSLY CALIFORNIA'S CHANGED
ENORMOUSLY SINCE THEN --
WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH A
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND HIS STAFF --
JAMAL WHO SPENT SO MUCH TIME
MAKING SURE THAT WE COULD COME
TO AN AGREEMENT --
ON THIS NUMBER ELEVEN IS FAIR
IT'S WORKABLE IT'S GOOD FOR THE
CONSUMER AND IT'S GOOD FOR THE
PROFESSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BOB THOUGHT CARILLO BEHALF OF A
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY. FOR BELIEVES THE
CURRENT LAWS ANTI COMPETITIVE
LIMITS ACCESS TO QUALITY VISION
CARE AND RESTRICTS CONSUMER
CHOICE THE BOARD SUPPORTIVE OF
REMOVING THE BRANCH OFFICE
LICENSE WHILE EXPANDING ACCESS
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THE BOARD SINCERELY THANK
SIMILAR MCGUIRE NEW STAFF FOR
THEIR TIRELESS WORK ON THIS BILL
WITH THE BOARD AND IT
STAKEHOLDERS OF THE CURRENT BILL
REFLECTS MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS
IN THE REQUIRE HELD WITH THE
BOARD AND VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS.
AND THE WORLD'S ALSO THANKS CO A
FOR THE WILLINGNESS TO COME TO
THE TABLE AND AMEND THIS
ANTIQUATED LAW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK.
SEEN ON ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NO WITNESSES OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM KUNO WAS AT THIS TIME
SENATE MCGUIRE DO WAS TO CLOSE.
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH DO ONCE I THINK JAMAL
SERVER OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING
ON THIS AS WELL IN RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AN
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THINGS ARE.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
PASSION ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
WILL TAKE THIS UP WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN WHICH IS S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR STONE
[inaudible]
THUNDERSTONE WELCOME.
BRENDA FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON PRESENTING SP
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR WHICH REQUIRE
A PHARMACIST AT A HOSPITAL TO
CONFIRM AN ACCURATE.
MEDICATION PROFILE FOR EACH HIGH
RISK PATIENTS UPON ADMISSION OF
THE PATIENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR.
AND HIS COMMITTEE FOR WORKING
WITH US ON S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
FOUR AND I'M VERY HAPPY. TO BE
TAKEN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY.
IT'S STARTING THAT UP 270% OF
PATIENTS HAVE ERRORS ON THEIR
MEDICATION LISTS UPON ADMISSION
TO HOSPITAL.
AND UP 259% OF THOSE AREAS HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO CAUSE MODERATE
TO SEVERE HARM.
THERE'S CURRENTLY A LACK OF
OVERSIGHT FOR ENSURING THAT SUCH
MEDICAL LISTS ARE ACCURATE UPON
HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS.
THIS LACK OF DEFINED
RESPONSIBILITY RESULTS AND
ERRORS IN THE LISTS AND ERRORS
IN MEDICATION ORDERS WHEN
PATIENTS ARE IN THE HOSPITAL AND
IN FACT WHEN THEY'RE DISCHARGED.
NOT ONLY DOES IS LEAD TO
SIGNIFICANT HARM TO THE PATIENT
BUT STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THIS
PROBLEM ALSO BECAUSE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
DUE TO MEDICATION RELATED PRE
ADMISSIONS AND ADVERSE DRUG
EVENTS.
THIS BILL WERE BETTER ENSURE THE
ACCURACY OF WHAT PATIENT
MEDICATION PROFILES ARE
ADMISSION.
THEREBY POTENTIALLY STOPPING ANY
ERRORS WHICH WILL ENHANCE
PATIENT SAFETY.
AND REDUCE POSITION IN HOSPITAL
I BILL [inaudible]
CHARGE.
I WOULD LIKE INTRODUCED DOCTOR
RIEDERS CHANGE HE PHARMACY
OFFICER FOR CEDAR SINAI HOSPITAL
LOS ANGELES AND PROFESSOR OF
MEDICINE.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO --
THANK YOU I COULD DRIVE A GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
CENTER COULD JUST PAUSE FOR A
MOMENT SO CAN ESTABLISH QUORUM
COMMITTEE SIC TRIP.
A LITTLE.
LOW HERE BROW.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BLOOM [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
JILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING.
GREAT NOW WE HAVE THE SUBS
CORBIN PLEASE.
ALLOW UP TO TWO MINUTES PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
HAVEL SENATOR STOTT AND TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR ALLOWING ME TO
DISCUSS WHAT I BELIEVE IS A
REALLY CRITICAL.
A PATIENT SAFETY ISSUE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO I'M GONNA
START WITH UP A PERSONAL
PERSPECTIVE --
TWENTY YEARS AGO ACTUALLY A LAST
MONTH MY FATHER WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH LUNG CANCER AND HAD SURGERY
IN A SERIES OF NEEDS FOR
MEDICATIONS AND AND I WAS KIND
OF STARTLED BY SOME OF THE
FINDINGS THAN ON HE WAS JUST
CONTINUED ON A MEDICATION THAT
WAS IMPORTANT TO PREVENT
SWELLING.
OF HIS BRAIN WHEN HE WAS ON
DISCHARGED TO ANOTHER HOSPITAL I
THAT THE HOSPITAL DID NOT KNOW
THAT HE WAS ON THE MEDICATION
WHICH CREATED ALL SORTS OF AND
TOWARD SIDE EFFECTS.
HE ALSO HAD OTHER --
COMORBIDITY TREATED EFFECTIVELY
JUST BECAUSE OF LAPSES IN
GETTING AN ACCURATE MEDICATION
HISTORY.
OF THE I VOWED THEN THAT THIS
WOULD BE MY CAREER GOAL TO MAKE
SOMETHING HAPPEN TO ENSURE THE
ACCURACY OF MEDICATION LAST.
MANY YEARS LATER MORE RECENTLY
MY ELDERLY AND HAD MULTIPLE
CONDITIONS AND WAS HOT
FREQUENTLY HOSPITALIZED DURING
WHAT'S UP ONE HOSPITALIZATION
HER ON MEDICATION FOR HER BREAST
CANCER WAS DISCONTINUED.
SHE WAS STARTED ON MEDICATIONS
FOR BLOOD PRESSURE SHE WAS
NINETY POUNDS AND THEY KEPT
INCREASING THE BLOOD PRESSURE
MEDS WHICH IS ALL THAT AND
THOUSAND SUBSEQUENT
HOSPITALIZATIONS.
THAT'S MY PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE
FROM MY PROFESSIONS PURPOSE
PERSPECTIVE HAVING BEEN A
PHARMACIST FOR FOR MANY MANY
DECADES I'VE WITNESSED ON THE
FACT THAT AND IN THE REAL LIFE
SETTING --
THESE MEDICATION LESS WHICH FORM
THE BASIS OF ORDERS.
ARE CREATED BY NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND DIFFERENT
PRACTICE SETTINGS ON A DOCTOR'S
OFFICE YOU MIGHT HAVE MEDICAL
ASSISTANT WHO'S MAYBE HAD FIVE
HOURS OF TRAINING IN ORDER ENTRY
TAKEN MEDICATION LIST.
THAT THEN BECOMES THE BASIS OF
FUTURE ORDERS AGAIN THROUGH MY
CAREER IN PHARMACY AYE WHAT
WITNESS THE EXPLOSION OF COMPLEX
NEW MEDICATIONS TO TREAT A
VARIETY OF DISEASES WE REALLY
HAVE A HUGE OUR MOMENTARY
MEDICATIONS AVAILABLE.
WE HAVE AN ELDERLY POPULATION
MANY TIMES PATIENTS ARE BEING
SEEN BY MULTIPLE --
PHYSICIANS AND SO THIS --
THIS AMBIGUITY IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THE MEDICATION LIST
AS ACCURATE AS PARTICULARLY AN
ISSUE WHEN PATIENTS ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE WHEN THEY'RE ADMITTED
TO OUR HOSPITALS.
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR HIGH
RISK PATIENTS WE TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE AS PART OF THE
HEALTHCARE TEAM CAN ENSURE THE
ACCURACY OF THE MEDICATION LIST.
SO THAT THE ORDERS THAT ARE
WRITTEN SUBSEQUENTLY ARE BASED
ON THE INTENT OF WHAT THE
PHYSICIAN DESIRED.
SO IN OUR ORGANIZATION WE LOOK
AT THIS TEAM BATES APPROACH AS A
THREE LEGGED STOOL SO THE
PHARMACIST ISRAEL IS THAT IS THE
MIDDLE OF THE STORE THE
PHYSICIAN IS THE ONE WHO'S
DETERMINING THE NEEDS OF THAT
PATIENT.
THE ACUTE NEEDS TO STABILIZE
THAT CREATE A PLAN OF CARE THAT
IS TO BE CARRIED OUT BY THE THE
OTHER HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
THE PHARMACIST INTERPRETS THAT
ORDER IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
PATIENT WE'RE NOT REPLACING.
ABOUT WITH A PHYSICIAN OR THE
NURSES WORK WHERE WHERE THERE AS
PART OF THIS THREE LEGGED STOOL.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT WE WE ALL
WEEK ALL COMPLETED TRAINING AND
IN ENGLISH AND KNOW THAT AND AND
HOW TO HOW TO CONSTRUCT A
SENTENCE HOW TO CONJUGATE --
OVER AND MEDICATION ORDERS A
SENSE OF THE DRUG THE DOES THE
ROUTE THE FREQUENCY THE DURATION
CRACKED THING WE'RE GONNA SEE
HARM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THINK ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO COME OF THEM --
MIKE AND NAY METHYLATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO.
MY NAME IS.
PAULA AND I SERVICES SECTION
CHIEF FOR HOSPITAL MEDICINE AT
UC DAVIS MEDICAL CENTER.
I ALSO SERVICE THE SITE
PRINCIPAL INVESTIGATOR FOR A
LARGE COLLABORATIVE TRIAL CALLED
THE MARQUEE STUDY --
MEDICATION RECONCILIATION
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT STUDY AND
THIS IS A LARGE TRIAL INCLUDING
OVER EIGHTEEN SITES LOOKING AT
BEST PRACTICES IN MEDICATION
RECONCILIATION.
AND I'LL JUST CUT TO OUR
CONCLUSIONS.
BASICALLY WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
PHARMACY TECHNICIANS --
GOING ON AND TAKING ACRID PRE
ADMISSION MEDICATION LESS WE
WERE ABLE TO CUT DOWN MEDICATION
DISCREPANCIES OR MEDICATION
ERRORS BY OVER 65%.
ON AVERAGE PATIENTS THAT SHOWED
UP AT OUR INSTITUTION HAD ABOUT
FIVE DISCREPANCIES OR MEDICATION
ERRORS.
PER PATIENT ON ADMISSION WE WERE
ABLE TO CUT THAT DOWN TO LESS
THAN.
ONE SO THE RESULTS WERE QUITE
DRAMATIC AND WE'VE.
I FOUND THAT --
THESE MEDICATION DISCREPANCIES
MEDICATION ERRORS LEAD TO LESS
ADVERSE EVENTS --
INCREASED --
SAVINGS IN TERMS OF COST
UTILIZATION.
SO WE FEEL STRONGLY THAT
PHARMACY TECHNICIANS HELPING TO
SUPPLEMENT POSITIONS --
REALLY DO OUR PATIENTS LOT OF
BENEFIT.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL ONES AS WHICH WAS
BEACON SPORT NAY MANIPULATION HE
WISHED TO DO SO.
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS WE WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR HIS RECENT
AMENDMENTS WERE IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD MORNING DAVID GONZALEZ
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCE ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORT
MY THINK CENTER FOR INTRODUCING.
GOOD MORNING LAURIE ANTI MARTINI
CEO FOR THE CALIFORNIA CITING
HEALTH SYSTEM PHARMACISTS ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEN NONE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
MY AS CHAIR MEMBERS TO MADDEN
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION.
WE JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT IF
A PHARMACIST OR PHARMACY
TECHNICIAN ISN'T AVAILABLE THAT
ANOTHER LICENSE PROFESSIONAL
COULD ALSO DO THE MEDICATION
PROFILE.
EVEN WORK WITH THE SENATOR ON
HE'S OPEN TO OUR AMENDMENTS --
AT THIS POINT WILL WORK OUT
MOVING.
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING CAN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES OPPOSITION --
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT'S ATOP
RATHER SHOCKING --
THAT THIS TYPE OF PROTOCOL
DOESN'T EXIST ALREADY --
FOR MANY OF US LIKE.
MET WITH THE DOCTOR SHANE THIS
MORNING CA ON WE HAVE OTHER
FRIENDS OR RELATIVES.
WHO AFTER HIM THIS IS
BENEDICTION WHEN THE AND IN THE
PAST AND WE ARE MORE AND MORE?
AND I AM NOT SAYING THIS IS THAT
THAT'S A NEGATIVE NECESSARILY
BUT WERE MORE AND MORE DEPENDENT
ON PHARMACOLOGICAL INTERVENTIONS
IN OUR HEALTH CARE.
SO THIS WOULD ONLY BE A GROWING
PROBLEM IN THE IDEA THAT WE MAKE
CERTAIN THAT.
THE MEDICATIONS THAT A PERSON IS
ON AT THE TIME OF TREATMENT IN
THE EMERGENCY ROOM OR ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
FOR THE FOR THAT MATTER.
IS I'D JUST TAKEN OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE.
SO I'M VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS A MEASURE FIGURE SOMETHING
BIG STEP FORWARD.
BEING THE VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE
INTENTIONAL CUT QUESTIONS COMES
FROM COMMEMORATIVE THIS TIME
SENATOR SO DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
HONORABLE OUR MEMBERS --
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BILL --
THERE IS A TRIAD TO CARE AND AS
THE PATIENT THE PHYSICIAN AND
THE PHARMACISTS AND WORKING
TOGETHER IN COLLABORATION WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN REDUCE THE
MORBIDITY AND MORTALITY
ASSOCIATED WITH DRUG ERRORS.
AND I STRONGLY URGE MY FELLOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER STONE
OF VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
EXPERTISE AND PASSION ON THIS
ISSUE IN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE WITNESSES WHO HAVE ALSO COME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
AND THIS DOES ENJOY AND AYE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH LOW AYE
AYE THOUGH I'D.
BRO I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
GEN I CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
OVERLOOKED IN OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
THAT HAS TWELVE AYE VOTES WILL
BE THERE OPEN PERHAPS NUMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER OF THE GUN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
WHICH IS S. B. TEN NINETY EIGHT
BY SENATOR CANNELLA.
SENATE CANNELLA AS YOU KNOW WE
ALSO HAVE FILE AND MEMBER NUMBER
FIVE WHICH IS S. B. NINE TWENTY
WHICH IS ON CONSENT COUNTER SO
YOU'LL JUST BE PRESENTING A FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX WHICH IS S. B..
TEN NINETY EIGHT BILL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER READING AGAIN
UP TO TWO MINUTES FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SIR S. B. TO NINETY
EIGHT REVISES THE CURRENT.
APPLICANT FEE STRUCTURE OF THE
BOARD OF PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS
LAND SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS.
THE FEE STRUCTURE CURRENTLY
OUTLINED IN THE GEOLOGISTS AND
GEOPHYSICISTS ACT HINDERS THE
BOARD FROM ESTABLISHING A
CONSISTENT EQUABLE FEE STRUCTURE
FOR ALL OF THE BOARDS APPLICANTS
AND LICENSEES.
THE FEE STRUCTURE PROHIBITS THE
BOARD FROM RECOVERING THE ACTUAL
COSTS INCURRED.
THE SERVICES PROVIDED TO
LICENSEES AND APPLICANTS THIS
BILL EQUALIZE THE BE STRUCTURE.
USE ME AND IS NOT PROPOSING ANY
NEW A FEE INCREASES WHICH ARE
REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS.
WITH UNIFIED TESTIMONY NATURI
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS RICK MORE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE BOARD
OF PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS --
WITH ELECTORAL AWARENESS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THE BOARD APPRECIATES ANY
CONSIDERATION THIS COMMITTEE HAS
ON THE SPELL AND WHILE WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO MOVING FOR
WITH IT I'M AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES ADDITIONAL BONUSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WE CAN MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
A THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL SENATOR I
HAVE A QUESTION THOUGH ABOUT THE
FEE INCREASE FOR SPECIALTY
GEOLOGIST AND SPECIALTY
GEOPHYSICIST.
OTHER MAX MOVIE GOES FROM ONE
HUNDRED TO FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
IT SEEMS LIKE A BIG INCREASE CAN
YOU TELL ME WHAT THE RATIONALE
WAS FOR THAT.
SELECT MORE HAPPY THINKS THAT.
I KNOW WE'RE NOT ANTICIPATING
THAT INCREASE THE GO TO FOR
HIGHER WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS THE ENGINEERS AND SURVEYORS
ACT.
STANDARDIZE ON A FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
ESTABLISH THE GEOLOGISTS
GEOPHYSICISTS BE THE SAME --
WE'RE NOT ANTICIPATING THAT
GOING ANYWHERE NEAR THAT AMOUNT
WE ARE DROPPING THE INITIAL
LICENSE FEE FROM ALL GEOLOGISTS
BASED LICENSES.
AND NOW OPEN THE STANDARDIZE
THAT TO BE A LITTLE MORE
APPROPRIATE WOULD WHETHER
PROFESSIONALS CHARGE IT WOULD
LIKE CIVIL ENGINEERS.
CIVIL ENGINEERS THE AROUND THE
RENEWAL FEE IS.
ONE THERE'S ONE FIFTEEN EVERY
TWO YEARS.
AND THE WORD DISSIPATING THAT
THE GEOLOGIST IF IT'S FEES WILL
BE SET SOMEWHERE TODAY ENGINEERS
AND SURVEYORS SO THE POINT IS
THAT'S THE MAXIMUM AS A CIVIL
ENGINEER I'M TO RENEW MY LICENSE
HERE A MONTH OR SO.
ALL PAY ONE FIFTEEN EVEN THOUGH
THE BOARD COULD GO UP
[inaudible]
TO THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU SEE EYES Y. SE
CENTER IT'S NICE TO SEE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ABOUT.
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND IN THE
AREA THAT YOU DOING LEGISLATION
IN BEING ABLE TO BRING YOUR
EXPERTISE TO THE TO THE TABLE ON
THIS AND ALSO PEOPLE DECIDE THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO INCREASE OR FEES ON
THEMSELVES I THINK IS VERY
PROFESSIONAL AND SHOWS REALLY
PROFESSIONAL INTEGRITY SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BILL THANK YOU.
COULD YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COULD MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE THAT SENATOR
CANNELLA IF YOU WISH TO CLOSE
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN THIS DOES ENJOY IN
AYE RECOMMENDATION THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
COMMITTEE SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
LOW LOW AYE BRO.
BROKE MY ARAMBULA.
BAKER SPEAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
THAT THAT CURRENTLY HAS TOLD AYE
VOTES WILL BE THE ROLE OF IS
PRACTICALLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IN THE CANAL.
EN EL LET'S NOW MOVE ON LONGER
WAITING FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS
THAT WE WILL TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AGAIN THAT.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND.
FOR TO MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR
COMMITS A TRIP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
AB NINE TWENTY MOTIONS YOU PASS
APPROPRIATIONS EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE MOTIONS DO PASTA
PREPARATIONS AB FOURTEEN NINETY
TWO MOTIONS YOU PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
LOW ART LOW EYEBROW.
BRO I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
OR WHEN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MULLIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
TING. TWELVE VOTES WILL BE THE
ROLE AT BEEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
.
OKAY -- WE
WILL THEN ALCHEMY SICK THEY WILL
GO THROUGH THE OF FILE.
ITEMS AGAIN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS TO ADD ON SO WE'LL START
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH
IS AS B. NINE FOUR SENATOR
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE'VE BY A SUMMER BLOOM THE
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN.
FILE AND IN A FOR S. B. NINE A
FOR S. B. NINE ZERO FOUR MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO DO TO TO SHERRY
LOW.
I'VE LOW AYE BRO.
BRO I ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER I BLOOM BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FUNG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MULLIN OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE
TING.
AND THAT HAS TWELVE AYE VOTES
AND LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY THEM GLOBAL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS S. B.
THIRTEEN OH FIVE AND THE THE
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND --
REFLECTING THE MEN'S IN THE
ANALYSIS A CONSTRUCTIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. THIRTEEN OH FIVE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO JUDICIARY
LOW I'VE LOW EYEBROW.
BRO I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FALL FONG AYE
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA?
MULLIN OBERNOLTE ABILITY AYE
TING.
THAT HAS TWELVE AYE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH IS S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
BEEN IN MOTION AND THIS OUR
SECOND THAT MOTION A SECOND.
RESEARCH A PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW OUR LOW
EYEBROW.
BRO I ARAMBULA.
BIGGER BIGGER AYE BLOOM.
WE MIGHT CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MEDINA AYE [inaudible]
MULLIN.
A RELATIVE OBERNOLTE AYE.
THAT HAS THIRTEEN AYE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS --
MEMBERS WE'VE NOW GONE THROUGH
THE ENTIRE FILE WE ARE WAITING
FOR ADDITIONAL AUTHORS AND AGAIN
BELIEVES THE ALLOW FOR UP TO
ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES FOR
AUTHORS TO ARRIVE AND THEN WE
WILL CLOSE.
SO AND THAT MEANTIME WE WILL BE
[inaudible]
PATIENTLY WAITING
.
OKAY WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
WIENER THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR WINNER FOR JOINING US
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHEN
YOU'RE READY AND AGAIN ALLOW UP.
TO TWO MINUTES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN TWO MINUTES IT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU BROUGHT TO
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING --
WITH -- AND
MYSELF ARE ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL [inaudible]
OKAY -- I S.
B. TWENTY NINE CREATES A NEW
LICENSE TWO EXAMS ARE LONG
STANDING COMPASSIONATE CARE
CANNABIS PROGRAMS.
I'M FROM PAYING THE EXCEL USE
AND CULTIVATION TAXES ON
CANNABIS THAT THEY DONATE HAVE
NO CHARGE OUGHT TO LOW INCOME
PATIENTS ARE PEOPLE LIVING WITH
HIV.
CANCER GLAUCOMA --
OTHER HEALTH CARE CONDITIONS --
ALLOWING THEM TO DONATE --
THE CANNABIS THE MEDICINE
WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY OUR TAXES
ARE THESE PROGRAMS HAVE EXISTED
FOR AYE DECADES IN CALIFORNIA --
THEY I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
STARTED BUT THEY STARTED IN A
MORE SIGNIFICANT WAY DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE HIV AIDS EPIDEMIC
WHERE PEOPLE WERE.
ISIS SO SECOND WAS NO EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT AND CANNABIS HELP THEM --
TO TO FEEL BETTER --
IF THIS MEDICINE IS MEDICINE --
AND PROP SIX BEFORE IT
LEGALIZATION --
I DON'T THINK THE VOTERS EVER
INTENDED --
TO BASICALLY SHUT DOWN THESE --
COLLECTORS AND WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW THESE ORGANIZATIONS
THEY DON'T CHARGE ANY MONEY THEY
HAVE NO REVENUE YET THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO PAY OUTSIDE SOME
CULTIVATION TAXES THEY ARE
SHUTTING DOWN --
AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO SHUT
DOWN ON PEOPLE WILL NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THEIR MEDICINE.
ARE AND SO THIS BILL WILL CREATE
A NEW --
LICENSE OUT SO THIS COOPERATIVES
CAN CONTINUE --
TO FUNCTION AND PEOPLE CA
CONTINUE TO HAVE OTHER MEDICINE --
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOAT AYE
WITH ME TODAY ARE FOREST'S HEARD
I'M FROM PLEDGE ITS NETWORK
WHICH IS THE COMPASSIONATE CARE
PROGRAM SERVING CATASTROPHICALLY
ILL PATIENTS.
AND A GALLON NOW GALLAGHER --
FROM SWEET LEAF COLLECTIVE ON
WHO HAS A COPY SENT --
WHO IS --
WILL TALK ABOUT --
HIS SITUATION TONIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY.
THIS PRESENT MANEUVER
[inaudible]
THE HOME.
I AM THE FATHER OF A CHILD WHEN
THIS GETS SO SYNDROME WHO'S
HAVING TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
SEIZURES A MONTH BEFORE A
COMPASSION PROGRAM IT ENABLED US
TO WORK.
WITH VERY SPECIALIZED MEDICINE
THEY ENDED UP SAVING SEIZURES
WHEN HE WHEN HE WAS A PROJECTED
TO LIVE PAST THE AGE OF TEN AYE
NOW DIRECTED ORGANIZATION OF THE
CLATTER SUMMER KILLS OF
CATASTROPHICALLY ILL CHILDREN.
THAT THE BOTTOM LINE IS IT'S THE
CURRENT MARKETPLACE IS NOT
EQUIPPED AND ABLE TO MEET THE
NEED OF RARE NEUROLOGICAL
CONDITIONS FOR PEOPLE WITH
TERMINAL ILLNESS.
THAT WE'VE BEEN SPECIALIZING IN
THAT FOR YEARS WE PARTNER WITH
THE EXISTING NETWORK AND WE
DONATE THOSE AT NO COST.
I WITH THE SUNSET INVEST THE
COLLECTION CAUSES AN SP FOUR
TWENTY WE HAVE THIS POINT NOW
WHERE WE HAVE CLIENTS THAT
DEPEND ON THE MEDICINE THEY'RE
NOT AVAILABLE ON THE REGULAR
MARKET.
AND WITH THE SUN SETTING OF THE
COLLECTIVE MODEL WE WOULD HAVE
TO STOP IN JANUARY FIRST PUTTING
A LOT OF FAT CHILDREN FAMILIES.
OF VETERANS OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
AND VERY DANGEROUS SITUATIONS
WITH TWENTY TWO VETERAN SUICIDE
TODAY WITH CATASTROPHICALLY ILL
CHILDREN DYING FROM WHERE
EPILEPSIES ADD WITH INTRACTABLE
EPILEPSY IS IT THAT SIGNIFICANT
RATES.
AT OUR SERVICES ARE ABLE TO
INTERJECT IN A COMPASSIONATE
MANNER AND WE REQUESTED AYE VOTE
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIFTY
SECONDS LEFT PLEASE.
WE NEED TO BE JUST AS FIFTY
SECONDS.
IT'S RIGHT.
FOR IT'S RIGHT FOR MINOR.
OUR TIME TO MORE RESEARCH
AIRLINES ARE GALLAGHER MORE
RESIDENTS FRANCISCO.
I GOT INFECTED WITH THE HIV
VIRUS ABOUT THIRTY FIVE YEARS
AGO.
AND DOESN'T SOUND THROUGH A WIN
A WHOLE BUNCH OF DIFFERENT MARK.
GOVERNOR SERVERS ARE GONE BLIND
AND NOW JUST RECENTLY DIAGNOSED
WITH CANCER --
YEAH I'M SORRY OR UNDER A LOT OF
MEDITATIONS ON HAVE A HARD TIME --
AREA ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO SWEET
LEAF WAS GIVING FREE MEDICAL
MARIJUANA BECAUSE I COULDN'T
AFFORD IT.
AND IS ABOUT THE ORIGIN THIS
MANEUVER TO KEEP ME ALIVE
BECAUSE OF THE VARIOUS ILLNESSES
I'VE HAD I I CAN'T --
EACH VERY WELL AND I'M LOSING A
LOT OF BODY WEIGHT NUMBERS
ENERGY -- I
AM SINCE JANUARY FIRST --
THERE'S A WARMER AND MEDICAL
MARIJUANA FOR FREE CAMPING ON A
LIMITED BUDGET I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY. TO PAY FOR IT AND
THROUGH THE SOME OF MY FRIENDS
ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR ME
[inaudible]
BUT OTHERWISE.
I'D BE DEAD IF IT WASN'T FOR
MEDICINAL MARIJUANA [inaudible]
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING THAT [inaudible]
SURFACED ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAY
MAY FILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF
OF EASE SOLUTIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF OF SONY
VOTE WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
NEXT WEEK LOS ON BEHALF OF FLOW
KANA AND ALSO WITH OPERATION
EVAC ONE TO THINK THE AUTHOR AND
THIRD SHARE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL AND TRANSPORT FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU.
AND CAL SEN ALARM POLICY ADVISER
TO THE CALIFORNIA COMPASSION
COALITION I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL I APPLAUD SENATOR
WIENER AND A MR LOW AND TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD
WORK CONSIDERING THE SPELL --
AND ALSO FOR THE PATIENT
TESTIMONY THINK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S PADDY O'BRIEN AB
AND THE NURSE MASA MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN CANNABIS IS NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND I'M ALSO A
DISPENSARY HONOR IN OAKLAND WITH
A AND TYPE LICENSE.
AND I THINK THAT THE SPELL IS
AND I HAVE.
DESPERATE NEED TO KEEP THE
COMPASSION AT THE I CORPS OF THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
AND I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
I MY NAME SHOWN KERN AND I RUN
WE FOR IS PROJECT WITH A LOT OF
GREAT VETS BACK HERE.
ON MY WE ALL WANT TO THANK
SENATOR WIENER FIRST --
ONE WORD I HEARD A LOT USED BY
THIS GROUP HERE STAKEHOLDERS AND
PROP SIXTY FOUR REALLY.
IGNORED SOME STAKEHOLDERS THE
POOR THE DISABLED THE SICK WHICH
IS A HUGE VETERAN POPULATION.
WE NEED A WAY TO RE ENFRANCHISE
THESE VETERANS IN THESE
CHILDREN'S INTO A SYSTEM BECAUSE
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT CLOSING DOWN
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE IN THE BLACK MARKET.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE WANT AND JAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS RALPH TRUEBLOOD I AM --
CHAIRPERSON OF THE BOARD OF THE
WAY I'M GROUP IN SANTA CRUZ ALSO
ON THE BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPASSION COALITION IS ONE
REMIND OUR LEGISLATORS.
OF THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE'VE SAVED THE
GENERAL PUBLIC OF CALIFORNIA
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR NINETEEN NINETY SIX
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IT DOESN'T LIMIT FILIATION
PLEASE THANK YOU HI MY NAME IS
DOUGLAS REAL I'M THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR THE SPEAKING
COMPASSION PROGRAM IN A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPASSION
COALITION.
WHEN THANK SENATOR WIENER IN THE
OTHER AUTHORS FOR FOR THIS BILL
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB TWENTY NINE THANK YOU?
YES MY NAME IS BILL CRANDALL
SIXTY TWO YEAR OLD DISABLED THAT
THE MEMBER WE FOR WARRIORS I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS IDEAL AFTER THE PAY
FRANCE I AM AND COFOUNDER OF
ALVEOLUS ADVOCACY AND THAT'S HOW
THE BILL AT MAJOR MY SON WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH LEUKEMIA SIXTEEN
MONTHS AGO.
UNABLE TO AFFORD --
CBD OIL QLOGIC'S NETWORK HAS
DONE WONDERS TO GIVE MY SON A
CALL IT BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE
WE SUPPORT THE BILL THINK IT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
RICH MILLER ON BEHALF AMERICANS
FOR SAFE ACCESS AND THE AMERICAN
ALLIANCE FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING WILLIAM AUTUMN
BURKE OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THIS.
I FEARED JASON BROUGHT UP TO
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU CENTER.
AND ANOTHER ROUND WITH THE WHITE
IMMIGRANT REPRESENTING THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE WITH
REMARKS THE DRAFTERS AND
SUPPORTERS OF PROP SIXTY FOUR
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CHAU LOGO CAN OUR ACCESS TO LOVE
AS HAVE WE SUPPORT WE HOPE
RECOMMENDATIONS AMENDMENTS FOR
FEE WAIVERS ARE CONSIDERED.
AND ON WE ARE I HAVE SERVED OUR
COMMUNITY FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS.
AND THE MEDICINE IS NOT GOING TO
BE AFFORDABLE AND THAT IS THE
FEE WAIVERS DEFINITELY NEEDED
FOR THE GROUPS TO GET THROUGH
THE GATE.
MY NAME IS KEVIN DOLLARS ARE GO
AND I'M THE FOUNDER OF THE MUCH
MOVEMENT --
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND SENATOR WIENER --
AND I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
NICHOLAS BRADLEY REPRESENTING
HERBS COLLECTIVE WEEK FORBES
WORRIES PROGRAM SAN JOSE AND
MARINE CORPS VETERAN.
HI I'M RYAN MILLER OF OPERATION
EVAC EDUCATING VETERANS ABOUT
CANNABIS AND AYE PRAYERFULLY.
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME SCOTT TAYLOR RALPH
MACCHIO TIRED FROM THE US NAVY
AT THIRTEEN I HAVE YEARS OF
EXPLOSIVE AUG HAMNER.
HOUSE PUT ON HUNDRED MILLIGRAM
FIT NO PATCHES EIGHTY MILLIGRAMS
OF VALIUM I'VE BEEN PUT ON XANAX.
SO MANY AS AS OUR EYES --
THIS PLANT HAS LITERALLY SAVED
MY LIFE I GOT MYSELF OF ALL THE
OPIOIDS AFTER BEING MEDICALLY
RETIRED.
AND TRY LINDA FORTY PLUS
COUNTRIES AND NO VETERAN CAN
AFFORD FIFTY FIVE DOLLAR EATS IN
A DISPENSARY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
COMPASSIONATE CAREAND PROVIDING
FOR VETERANS IT'S CRAZY THAT THE
TO MY MAILBOX AND OPIE ALWAYS
LIKE CRAZY BUT THERE'S SO MANY
RESTRICTIONS ON THIS PLANET
SPEAKING AS A VETERAN TRYING TO
SAY VETERANS LIVES.
AND I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND ALL
THIS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
JEFFREY O. FROM MOM SOCO
VETERANS COALITION.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. TWENTY
GOALS CHAIR SAN FRANCISCO
CHAPTER OF AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS I JUST LIKE TO THINK --
CENTER WIENER AND I SAY I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO I'M DENISE STORY FROM AXIS
OF LOVE.
AND ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CENTER CITY DEMOCRATS.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
IN THE FEE WAIVER.
I'M DEALING WITH LYME DISEASE
AND I HAVE TO BATTLE THE NOT
ONLY OTHER.
POLICE JUST TO HAVE MY HERB.
BUT I ALSO HAVE TO BATTLE THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY JUST YOU GET
TREATED FOR LYME DISEASE BECAUSE
NO ONE TREATS US FOR FOR AND
CANNABIS IS ABOUT THE ONLY HOPE
WE REALLY HAVE BESIDES MOUNTAINS
OF ANTIBIOTICS THAT DESTROYS
LIVER.
SO CANNABIS IS JUST ABOUT THE
ONLY THING REASON WHY I'M ABLE
TO EVEN MAKE IT HERE.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS MORE
THAN YOU'LL EVER KNOW MY COUSIN
HAD HEART DISEASE.
HE PASSED AWAY FROM IT BUT HE
LIVED A LOT LONGER THAN ANYONE
ELSE WITH THAT CONDITION.
ALLEN HIT IN HISTORY BECAUSE HE
TOOK CANNABIS BUT HE COULDN'T
FOR HE GOT TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH.
AND HE STILL COULDN'T AFFORD TO
BUY THE BY ALL THE CANDIDATES HE
NEEDED TO STAY ALIVE.
SO I THINK YOU FOR THIS VERY
MUCH TEARS.
I UN NICK BUNGEE WE FOR WARRIORS
PROJECT SACRAMENTO HOME I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS PROJECT I WENT FROM
TAKING [inaudible] TWENTY NOT
NORCO PILLS A DAY TO NOT TAKE
ANY AND WITH.
HOW MUCH EVERYTHING IS INCREASE
THE PRICE IS BE IN A DISABLED
VET THERE'S NO WAY?
TO FORTY SO BASICALLY THE ONLY
OTHER OPTION IS.
GOING BACK TO THE VA TO GET THE
OPIATES TO HANDLE THE PAIN.
SO TO ME THAT'S NOT AN OPTION AT
ALL SO I HOPE YOU GUYS SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECKY.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANTHONY RANGEL
I AM THE CO FOUNDER OF THE E.
SPACE DOING ALLIANCE A FIVE OH
ONE C. FOUR ORGANIZATION BASED
SEVEN LIVERMORE.
I'M WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND THANK SENATOR WIENER
FOR ACTUALLY TAKING THE MOVES TO
PROTECT THE SERIOUSLY SICK AND
SUFFERING THAT WE SOUGHT TO
PROTECT WITH PROPOSITION.
TWO FIFTEEN HI MY NAME'S BRANCH
WISER I'M A COMBAT VETERAN I
LIKE TO THINK SENATOR WIENER FOR
TAKING THIS THAT --
I'VE I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
AS CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PULL IT OR WE HAVE THE SITTING
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
SPECIFICALLY THE OFFICE OF
CANNABIS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
I GREW UP IN CENTERS UP FOR
SUPPORT THANK YOU ARE SENATE
WHEN YOU FOR BRINGING THIS TO
THE USE OF FORCE ATTENTION.
I AM A REPRESENTATIVE OF BLACK A
BROWN JUST CAMPUS POLICY SAN
FRANCISCO AS WELL AS THEIR
COLLECTIVE --
MANAGING MYSELF OF THE RULES
KEEN GROUP AND WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
YOU'RE GOING ASSURE RULING THE
RULING.
ON JASON BEEN ALONE I'M ASSURING
YOU MEMBER ACTIONS THE OWE THEM
ALMOST WELL.
I'M BROUGH THIS HIM SHE CRIED
FOUNDATION IS HAUNTED PART IN
RESERVE ME MUCH OUR OWN THEIR
FEE WAIVERS.
OWN [inaudible]
BURKE.
I WAS NEVER SURE PROPOSAL LUNAR
ARE I WILL EVER DOES.
IN INDIA ALBUM.
I'M THE ONLY ONE JOKES HUMOR AYE
LIVE THERE FLOW OF LIFE EVERY
AGE PERSIAN DEL HOME BROWN.
GOOD OVERCOME [inaudible]
THE SO WHERE IS.
KEY PERSON YOUR* AND THEN
PURSUED BILL WEAR THEM FOR THEIR
VOTE THREE THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CRAIG OWNER OUR
SON ROMAN HAS EPITOMIZES BELOW
SAY AND WE RECEIVED PRODUCTS
FROM THE CLERK AT THE KALACHURIS
NETWORK THAT ARE HUGELY
IMPACTFUL AND WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RICHARD MANNING ARMOR
IN THE UNITED STATES MARINE
CORPS DISABLED BUT I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
NOT ONLY FOR DISABLED VETS BUT
MY MOTHER'S WELL WHO CAN AFFORD
MEDICINES INTERACTION NEEDS
MEDICAL CANNABIS FOR HER ILLNESS
AS WELL AS MINE.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S THAT THOMAS FULTON --
US ARMY THAT I WENT FROM TAKING
FIVE PILLS EVERY DAY I ONLY TAKE
ONE FOR SLEEP NOW SO.
UNSUPPORTED BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NEIL YARBOROUGH I'M A
U. S. M. C. --
MARINE CORPS BRAT ON MICE TAKE
FIFTEEN TWENTY THIRTY PILLS
[inaudible]
A DAY. TWO YEARS AGO YOU
WOULDN'T SEE ME OUTSIDE I'D I'D
BE MY HOUSE HIDDEN AWAY.
FROM THE PUBLIC.
WITHOUT WE FOR YEARS IN THE
CANNABIS THEY PROVIDE.
I PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY.
HI I'M GABLE YARBOROUGH I'M HIS
WIFE.
AND I'VE LIVED WITH THAT I'VE
LIVED WITH.
THIS BETTER AND TAKING ALL THE
PILLS THAT THE VA'S GIVEN HAVE.
YOU ONLY SEE IS BEHAVIOR GET
WORSE THAN OR HARDENED AND HAS.
A PASSION FOR OTHER PEOPLE TO
BECOME UGLY AND ANGRY. TO ONLY
WANT TO BRING THE WAR. TO ALL OF
US.
I AS A SPOUSE WOMEN.
COMPLETE SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IF
YOU GUYS CAN TAKE FULL STRESS
FROM A SPOUSE IS A BECAUSE
SUPPORT THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND CALCRAFT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BRIAN BACH IS CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS COALITION
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA MINORITY LINES INLAND
EMPIRE CHAPTER.
I WANNA STILL ALL LOOK AT ONE
THING ESPECIALLY MY MENTOR CRAIG
BEARISH THE AUTHOR OF
PROPOSITION TWO FIFTEEN AND
PORTIONS OF SENATE BILL FOUR TWO
I WOULD SAY.
PATIENTS OVER PROFITS AND EVEN
AS A PERSON WHO HAD AN INTEGRAL
ROLE TO PROP SIXTY FOUR THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO LOOK
AT AS PIVOTAL AND TIME CHANGING
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT TRULY.
LEGITIMATELY NEED THIS MEDICINE
THAT IS ONE THING WITH TAXES AND
TALKING ABOUT STAKEHOLDERS IN
LOOKING AT THE FISCAL IMPACTS OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WE'VE
OVERLOOKED.
IS THAT WHAT THIS WILL DO FOR
PEOPLE.
EVERY FORGET WHAT THIS DOES FOR
PEOPLE WHAT IN GENERAL WHAT IT'S
ABOUT IS THE PEOPLE.
THAT WE ACTUALLY LOST SIGHT OF
WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT WHEN IT
COMES TO SOMETHING AS MEDICAL
MARIJUANA EVEN RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA.
SAW AS TRUE CHAMPION TO THE BILL
SARAH WIENER THANK YOU.
THIS IS TRULY NECESSARY WE ARE
PROUD SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
Q..
THEN MOVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
AND THE CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE.
OTHERS THE PREVAILING ATTITUDE
MAYBE NOT PREVAILING BUT TO SUIT
ADDED TO THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
NOW. TO WAIT.
ON THE OVERLOOKED ITEMS AND
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES UNTIL
NEXT YEAR.
THIS IS ONE MATTER THAT'S NOT WE
CAN'T WAIT PEOPLE NEED THE FREE
MEDICINE.
SO PLEASE MOVE THIS FORWARD
THANK YOU.
NOT MOVE THE SEPTEMBER INSIGHTS.
MY NAME'S COVERAGE THEN.
I'M WITH THE WHEAT FOR YEARS
PROJECT I'M ALSO A SUICIDE
SURVIVOR --
THEY HAD STATED THE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO VETERANS COMMIT
SUICIDE EVERY DAY IT'S ACTUALLY
WAY WORSE THAN THAT.
THOSE STATISTICS ARE NOT FULL
THEY'VE THROWN OUT ONE THIRD THE
STATISTICS --
IF IT'S A DRUG RELATED ISSUE AND
IT'S NOT ALWAYS CONSIDERED A
SUICIDE COULD BE AN OD.
CALIFORNIA TEXAS MAKE UP.
THE MAJORITY OF OUR ARMED
SERVICES.
AND A LOT OF VETERANS IN THE
STATE ARE COMMITTING SUICIDE I
HAVE A QUOTE.
THAT I WANT TO READ --
BECAUSE I'M NOT HERE TO TRY TO
CONVINCE YOU.
ARE HERE TO APPLY YOUR
HEARTSTRINGS.
PEOPLE NOWADAYS WILL OFFER
CONDOLENCE IN DEATH FASTER THAN
THEY WILL OFFER COMPASSION IN
LIFE.
THEY WILL RUIN YOUR PEACE WHILE
YOU'RE HERE.
BUT THEN PRAY FOR YOUR ARREST.
WHEN YOU LEAVE?
A LOT OF VETERANS ARE DYING AND
I'M PRAYING THAT YOU GUYS OFFER
COMPASSION NOW AND NOT
CONDOLENCE IN THEIR DEATH.
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH THIRTIES
I'M A NAVY VETERAN SINGLE MOM
AND TALKED TO PRESIDENT OF WE
FOR WARRIOR PROJECT IN SAN JOSE --
THANK YOU MISTER WEINER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL [inaudible]
STATE --
WITHOUT THE CBD PRODUCTS I GET
FROM THE COMPASSION PROGRAMS --
I HAVE TO TAKE ANTI ANXIETY
MEDICATION.
ANTIDEPRESSANT MEDICATIONS THAT
SLOW ME DOWN AND SOMETIMES WITH
THE OTHER AVAILABLE TO MY
CHILDREN.
WITH THE CVT PRODUCTS AND THE
OTHER THINGS THAT WE GET THROUGH
THE COMPASSION PROGRAMS.
I'M ABLE TO BE THERE FOR MY
CHILDREN.
SO THANK YOU FOR THIS AND I HOPE
CHATHAM.
YOU BEFORE IT THANK YOU.
AND CRISPER CITY MEMBER REFER
WARRIORS.
MOST SO CANCER SURVIVOR I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI AND JOSEPH ARONIE FOUNDER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE SWEET LEAF
COLLECTIVE I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER FOR PRESENTING
THIS BILL --
WE HAVE BEEN PROVIDING FREE
CANNABIS TO LOW INCOME
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS IN SAN
FRANCISCO SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THINK.
WELL HA GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JONATHAN DYER I AM A MEMBER OF
OF THE AXIS OF LOVE AND I HAVE
MEDICAL CONDITIONS --
THAT ALLOW ME --
TO BE ABLE TO PURCHASE OF
MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
BUT I WAS ACTUALLY ABLE --
TO AFFORD TO BUY SOME STUFF --
ON LIFE IN ONE OF THE
DISPENSARIES BUT THAT WAS
BECAUSE THEY HAD A 70% OFF SALE.
OKAY SO THEN WHEN I I WAS ABLE
TO BY THIS STUFF SO I GET THE
RECEIPT.
YOU GET THE RECEIPT YOU ACTUALLY
ABLE TO SEE WHERE YOUR MONEY'S
GOING WHAT MONIES BEING SPENT ON
ONE SO IT TURNS OUT THAT THE
MARIJUANA TAX IS ACTUALLY MORE
THAN SALES TAX.
THAT THAT THE STATE HAS WHICH IS
VERY VERY HIGH WHICH WHICH MAKES
IT IF IT THIS WORK 1100% RETAIL
THING.
THE PRODUCT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
LIKE ON AFFORDABLE BE ON A TANK%
YOU SIR IF YOU COULD JUST ABOUT
WRAP UP QUICKLY OF A LOT OF
TESTIMONY HERE AND
AFOREMENTIONED I HAVE I HAVE
WAVES SO THAT PEOPLE CAN.
BE ABLE TO AFFORD THE PRODUCT
THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR.
NATIONAL WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
YOUR NAME AND GROUP AFFILIATION
PLEASE MORE CARRILLO UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS COMBAT
VETERAN FROM SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU SENATOR INTEREST
YOUR TEAM FOR PUT IN THE WORK.
I'M A TAKE TIME MORE SECOND
SHAUN PRESENTLY FORCE WE NEED A
BILL THAT WORKS FOR THE PATIENTS.
NOW AFTER THE DISPENSARIES NOT
FOR CORPORATE CANNABIS FOR THE
PATIENTS THANK YOU.
ROBERT HARRISON DE HAVE HAVE SEE
I CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL WE GOTTA REMEMBER THAT
SWEETLY AND WHAM WHERE THE
MODELS FOR WHEN WE GET SB. FOUR
TWENTY TO MAKE IT SO THE COOPS
COULD WORK TO GET RID TRULY SICK
PEOPLE.
MEDICINES ARE BACKED.
MY NAME'S PATTY SITE OFTEN AND
THE GRANDPARENT TOOK A NINE YEAR
OLD LITTLE SWEETHEART WHO HATH
INTRACTABLE EPILEPSY.
HE POLICE RECEIVES CALOTTERY US
NETWORKS BENEFIT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU IT'S MADE A
HUGE DIFFERENCE I WAS HAVING TO
SPEND MY RETIREMENT FOR HIS
MEDICATION [inaudible]
IT'S I'M SOME BIG SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS MIGUEL DOMINATE
REPRESENTING THE MUCH MOVEMENT.
WE ARE FEEDING THE HOMELESS WE
SPEAK TO A LOT OF VETERANS ALL
DAY EVERYDAY.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK.
HI MY NAME IS ROBIN KRISTIN PARA
I AM A MOM OF A MILITARY PERSON
I REPRESENT THE WAIT FOR YEARS.
AND PLEASE WERE JUST BEGGING
YOUR KIDS WANT TO GET OFF THE
DRUGS AND JUST WANT TO DO
SOMETHING NATURALLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL USE.
THE IDEA MONEY OF SANDERS ANCHOR
AND I STATES NAVY HARDCORE
PROJECT I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MORNING DEAL SCHAEFER ON COUNCIL
FOR WEEK FOR WARRIORS MEMBER OF
THE CAT CALIFORNIA COMPASSIONATE
COALITION.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER WE NEED
TO WORK WORK THIS OUT SO PEOPLE
DO NOT SUFFER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
CAMINO AMBER'S AT THIS TIME --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
LET ME FOR START BY SAYING I'VE
HAD A COUPLE CONVERSATIONS THE
LAST FEW DAYS WITH SOME STAFF
AND SOME COLLEAGUES WHO.
ARE LESS FAMILIAR WITH THESE
PROGRAMS SO I JUST WANT TO CHIME
IN AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN A LONG
TIME SUPPORTER.
OF COMPASSIONATE CARE CANVAS
PROGRAM.
THE COMPASSION AND THE CARE OF
THOUSANDS OF MY CONSTITUENTS ARE
WHO ARE PATIENTS WHO ARE LOW
INCOME.
ELDERLY DISABLED VETERANS
SUFFERING FROM HEALTH AILMENTS
FOR WHICH MEDICAL CANNABIS FROM
THESE PROGRAMS WERE THE ONLY
THINGS THAT HAVE HELPED.
AND CLEARLY PROP SIXTY FOUR HAD
A SEVERE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF ENDANGERING THESE PROGRAMS
AND SO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE.
ALL THE AUTHOR AND THE COALITION
BEHIND THIS AND I JOIN OUR
COLLEAGUES IN ASKING THAT WE
MOVE THIS BILL FROM THIS
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU ALSO JUST SAYING I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT PROGRAM
MIGHT LAST BUT A LOT OF FRINGES
OF CANCER AND HIV AIDS WHO ARE
ABLE.
TO BUT USE MEDICAL CANNABIS BUT
ALWAYS NOT TO A COMPASSION
PROGRAM SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD I
LIKE TO SEE IT ALSO MORE BROADLY
ACROSS THE STATE FOR PEOPLE TO
HAVE THIS KIND OF ACCESS.
BECAUSE IT IS NOW THE PEOPLE ARE
JUST GETTING FROM OTHERS WHICH
ISN'T VISITORS FORCES PEOPLE TO
BREAK THE LAW IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN THEIR HEALTH.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TYPE.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMANDERS SENATOR
WIENER DO WISH TO CLOSE OUR I
THANK YOU AYE AYE SIR AYE VOTE
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH --
COMMITTEE GOING FORWARD I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE ALTHOUGH
COLLABORATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR WE
KNOW AS YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS ON THIS
ISSUE IN RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE ISSUE THAT WE
NEED TO ADDRESS.
BECAUSE PROP PROCEDURALLY THIS
WAS A GUT AND AMEND OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS ONLY HAD.
SEVEN WORKING DAYS TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THE APPROPRIATE ALICE'S
AND THE NEW LICENSURE CATEGORY A
TYPE --
WHICH IS INSUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF
TIME HAVING SAID THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE IDENTIFY THESE
ISSUES AND TRYING TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD.
A SO THAT WE CAN HAVE ALL FULLER
CONVERSATION.
SO OF WITH THAT SAID I WITH THIS
DOESN'T JOIN AYE RECOMMENDATION
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
WIENER.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAX LOW.
LOW AYE BROWN.
BROUGH NOT VOTING ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU AYE CHIU AYE
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I FALL [inaudible]
GIPSON.
IT'S AN AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MULLIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
BUT LOOK YOU KNOW TING
[inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE VOTE IS NINE TO ONE BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NOW SENATOR --
WE KNOW WE'LL MOVE ON IF YOU ARE
EVER ABLE A FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN WHICH IS S. B..
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I MISTER CHAIRMAN
AGAIN THANK YOU TO YOU AND YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
BILL -- AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
THAT IT THEM VOTES.
I'M S. B. --
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO REQUIRES OF
PHARMACIES TO ENSURE --
THAT ANOTHER STAFF MEMBER AYE
SUCH AS THE CLERK OR A PHARMACY
TECHNICIAN AND IS AVAILABLE TO
ASSIST IN THE PHARMACY --
WHENEVER A PHARMACIST IS AT WORK --
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
SLATE OF AND STRAIGHT OF ACTIONS
OF GIVING CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS.
GREATER AND GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE DIRECT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WHETHER
CHECKING --
FOR OPIOID ADDICTION PROVIDING
VACCINATIONS OR CONTRACEPTION
UNFORTUNATELY PHARMACISTS ARE
OFTEN UNABLE TO CARRY OUT THESE
DUTIES IN A SAFE AND EFFECTIVE
MANNER.
OF ALL SIMULTANEOUSLY ANSWERING
THE PHONE RINGING UP GROCERIES
OR HANDLING A LONG LINE OF
IMPATIENT CUSTOMERS ARE WAITING
FOR SERVICE.
OP PHARMACISTS OFTEN CANNOT EVEN
LEAVE TO USE THE RESTROOM
WITHOUT SHUTTING DOWN THE
PHARMACY I ENTIRELY --
WE ARE AWARE OF PHARMACISTS YOU
FOR FOUR SIX OR EVEN AN EIGHT
HOUR SHIFT ARE ALONE THE ENTIRE
TIME EXPECTED TO RUN EVERYTHING
WORK WITH OUT HIS HANDS.
AND TIED TO THEIR OWN NEEDS --
AND IT'S REALLY NOT TENABLE --
THIS ISSUE IS PREVALENT --
AT LARGE TEAM RETAIL PHARMACIES
AND THAT'S WHAT THE BILL FOCUSES
ON ON S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY TWO
EXCLUDES HOSPITAL PHARMACIES
SMALL MOM AND POP PHARMACIES
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT REALLY WHERE
THE ISSUE IS --
AND OTHERS WERE REQUIRING
PHARMACIST [inaudible]
LOS AN ISSUE.
S. B. FORTY FORTY TWO IS
SUPPORTED BY THE STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
AMONG OTHER SUPPORTERS AND WILL
HELP ENSURE THE PHARMACIST CAN
SUCCEED AND PERFORMING THEIR
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT HEALTH CARE
RESPONSIBILITIES --
I WANT TO THANK US SENATOR STONE
UPPER JOINT OFFERING THIS BILL
WE DO ENJOY BIPARTISAN A SUPPORT --
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU'RE UP
HERE I GO --
AND I'LL SO GOING --
BY ISAAC MERRETT BE FROM UNITED
FOOD COMMERCIAL WORKERS.
DO YOU THINK YOU MISUNDERSTOOD
YOU WISH TO ADD ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS --
FIRST OF ALL LET ME SAY I'M VERY
PROUD -- TO
WORK WITH SENATOR WIENER ON THIS
BILL.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW I AM A
REGISTERED PHARMACIST AND STILL
IN GOOD STANDING WITH THE STATE
BOARD OF PHARMACY STILL OWN A
PHARMACY ALBEIT ACCOUNT COUNTY
PHARMACY --
BUT I DID WORK --
FOR CHAIN STORES --
RIGHT AFTER I WAS LICENSE SAVE
SOMEONE AFFECT THEIR WORK FOR
PHARMACY JOBS TO SAVE ENOUGH
MONEY DON'T MY FIRST OF SIX
PHARMACIES.
IT WAS A BIG DEAL --
AFTER I GRADUATED THAT --
OUR SCOPE OF PRACTICE ACTUALLY
INCREASE OR RE COULD LEGALLY
TAKE BLOOD PRESSURES AND REPORT
TO PATIENT WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAD HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE LOW
BLOOD PRESSURE TO GO SEE A
POSITION.
AND CERTAINLY WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE PAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN A PHARMACIST NOW SHE'S
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS.
HARD TO BELIEVE HOW FAST TIME
GOES BY BUT OUR OUR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE IS INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY AS MANY.
A CONSIDER PHARMACIST TO ME THE
MOST OVERLY TRAINED UNDER
UTILIZE HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
AS MY COLLEAGUE GOT MENTIONED WE
DO US NICOTINE ABATEMENT
SERVICES WHICH IS.
JUST NOT A SIMPLE IS PULLING OUT
A BOX OF NICORETTE OFF THE SHELF
AND YOU JUST PRESCRIBING IT AND
GIVING IT TO TO A PATIENT --
YOU NEED TO KNOW HOW WHAT THEIR
HABIT IS YOU NEED TO HOW MUCH
NICOTINE TO GET THEM YOU TO WARN
THEM THEY SHOULDN'T SMOKE
NICOTINE AT THE SAME TIME THAT
THEY'RE CHEWING THE GUM OR
PUTTING PATCHES ON IMMUNIZATIONS
I MEAN --
VERY SIMPLE QUESTIONS NEED TO BE
ASKED THE PATIENTS ARE YOU
ALLERGIC TO EGGS BECAUSE THESE
IMMUNIZATIONS ARE CULTURED IN
EGGS AND IF YOU HAVE AN EGG
ALLERGY YOU COULD OF A
ANAPHYLACTIC REACTION.
SOBRE REQUIRED TO KEEP
ADRENALINE THEIR CASE SOMEBODY
DOES HAVE AN ANAPHYLACTIC
REACTION AND CERTAINLY
CONTRACEPTIVES WE NEED TO GET
HISTORIES.
ALL AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE TO
BE FILLING PRESCRIPTIONS.
AND AS ASSISTANT PROFESSOR U. S.
C. FOR COMMUNITY PHARMACY I
ALWAYS MADE SURE MY STE MY
STUDENTS WENT THROUGH WHAT I
WOULD CALL A TRIPLE CHECK SYSTEM
YOU ONLY GET.
A FEW MINUTES TO LOOK AT A
PRESCRIPTION WHEN YOU'RE
OVERSEEING TO TAX YOU HAVE TO
OVERSEE EIGHT PATIENT PROFILE.
OUGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT SOMEBODY
ISN'T SHOPPING PHARMACIES FOR
OPIATES WE HAVE AN OP A PROBLEM
WE DON'T MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
DISPENSING OPIATES TO PEOPLE
THAT ARE.
NEEDED TO A GOT A REFILL A WEEK
EARLIER THAT SHOULD LASSEN
THROUGH THREE WEEKS.
SO THIS TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITIES ON PHARMACIST
TODAY AND IT'S NOT UNCOMMON THAT
MANY OF THESE COMPANIES ARE --
PUBLIC COMPANIES AND THEY WANT
TO INCREASE DO IT UNFORTUNATELY
IS THEY WILL PULL STAFF AWAY.
AND WHEN PEOPLE STAFF AWAY THAT
MEANS THE PHARMACISTS HAVE TO
ANSWER THE PHONES IT IS A
PHARMACIST DEL HAS TO GIVE THE
IMMUNIZATION.
A MEANS OF THE PHARMACIST US
TAKE THE ORAL PRESCRIPTION OVER
THE PHONE FROM A PHYSICIAN THAT
CANNOT BE DONE --
BY TECHNICIAN MUST BE DONE BY
THE PHARMACIST AND THEN THE
PHARMACISTS HAVE TO CHECK THE
WORK.
OF THE TECHNICIAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE APPROPRIATE DRUGS IN
THE MODEL THE APPROPRIATE DOSES
IN THE BOTTLE THAT THERE'S NOT A
DRUG INTERACTION WITH SOMETHING
THAT MAYBE THEY'RE ALSO TAKING.
AND THIS IS WHY THERE'S A
CHALLENGE TODAY THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
THE CHECK THAT WAS CALLED A
PHARMACIST IN CHARGE.
AND MANY EXPERIENCE PHARMACISTS
DON'T WANT THAT JOB BECAUSE THEY
SEE IT AS A DISASTER IN THE
MAKING BECAUSE MISTAKES ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THE APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT.
AND AND HELP WITH PHARMACISTS
SHOULD NOT BE --
RINGING OUT NON PHARMACEUTICAL
SALES --
BECAUSE THE LINES ARE ARE TOO
BIG AT THE AT THE FRONT OF THE
STORE.
AYE AYE ONE JUST SHOW YOU ONE
LITTLE PIECE OF EVIDENCE MISTER
ABOUT CHAIR IF I MAY THIS IS --
THE PUBLIC OR RECORDS REQUEST BY
THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY JUNE
FIRST TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
AUGUST THIRTY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
AND SEVENTEEN THESE ARE ALL.
VIOLATIONS.
A CHAIN STORES.
AND I WOULD ALLEGE.
IN APPLYING THAT PROBABLY 80% OF
THESE.
ARE BECAUSE THE PHARMACIST
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME. TO DO
THEIR JOBS.
AND THEY WERE WRITTEN VIOLATIONS.
AS WELL AS THE PHARMACY AND THEY
GO ON PROBATION AND MANY CASES
SEE ESPECIALLY YOUNG PHARMACISTS
TO COME OUT OF SCHOOL THEY SAY
ELECT WILL GIVE A COUPLE BUCKS
AN HOUR TO BE THE PHARMACISTS IN
CHARGE.
AND COMING OUT OF SCHOOL WITH
HIGH DEBT SAY SURE WILL TAKE ON
THAT RESPONSIBILITY NOT KNOWING
THAT.
WHILE THEIR HOME IN A PHARMACIST
ISN'T DOING THEIR JOB AND THEY
MAKE AN ERROR THAT THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE AS WELL FOR THAT.
FOR THAT AIR THAT HAPPENED WHEN
THEY WERE EVEN IN THE PHARMACY
AND THAT'S WHY PHARMACIES ARE
HAVING TROUBLE RECRUITING FOR
PHARMACISTS IN CHARGE SO.
YOU KNOW.
AN EXTRA THIRTY SECONDS EXTRA
MINUTES IS ENOUGH FOR A
PHARMACIST TO BE ABLE TO CHECK
THAT BOTTLE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THIS MEDICATION THAT'S REQUIRED
IN.
DOSAGES RIGHT IN THE DIRECTIONS
ARE RIGHT THE POSITION IS RIGHT.
AND THERE'S NO DRUG INTERACTIONS
TO VERY COMPLEX JOB WITH A LOT
OF LIABILITY IF THINGS ARE DONE
RIGHT.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY GOOD
SUGGESTION TO HAVE ONE ANCILLARY
PERSONNEL --
IN YOUR HERE PROBABLY --
CHAIN STORE SAY WELL WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE OPEN THE PHARMACY
IN THE MORNING IN THE PHARMACY
STAFF DOESN'T SHOW.
WELL THAT MEANS OF THE FOR THE
MANAGER OF THE STORE CAN TAKE
ONE OF THE CASHIERS UP FRONT.
THE PUT IN THE PHARMACY YOU
CAN'T ILL ANYBODY BY SELLING
SOMETHING OVER THE COUNTER AT
THE FRONT OF THE STORE WHICH YOU
COULD HURT SOMEBODY IF A
PHARMACIST AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. TO YOU OUT REAP THE TO
REVIEW OF THE WORK THE
DISPOSITIVO ACTUALLY FOR THOSE
REASONS I STRONGER TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
SHOWN UP TO TWO MINUTES PLEASE
WHATEVER.
THAT YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JIM ARAVINDAN
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE US
W. S. OR STATES COUNCIL
REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND PRIVATE SECTOR WORKERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING THOUSANDS OF
PHARMACISTS.
AND SPECIFICALLY ON BEHALF OF
OUR THOUSANDS OF PHARMACIES
MISTER CHAIRMAN UCW IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SURVEYED OUR
MEMBER PHARMACISTS IN THE SURVEY
REVEALED.
THE FOLLOWING RESULTS FROM OF A
HUNDRED PHARMACISTS AND WE DID
THIS IN LESS THAN THREE DAYS 83%
SAY THEY ARE LEFT ALONE DURING
THEIR SHIFT.
THE AVERAGE TIME ALONE WAS FOUR
HOURS MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT'S
HALF OF THE SHIP.
NO WHOPPING 91% RESPONDED THAT
BEING LEFT ALONE IMPAIR THEIR
ABILITY TO PERFORM THEIR CORE
FUNCTIONS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND WANT TO THANK MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND ALL YOUR STAFF
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHICH GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS AND SHARE MY
NAME IS TIM AND RADHA I'M OF
PHARMACISTS WITH A GROCERY CHAIN
PHARMACY FROM SAN DIEGO BEEN
WITH THEM FOR NINE YEARS --
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
I DO --
ENJOY THE FACT THAT IN THE TIME
FRAME THAT IT WORKED AS A
PHARMACIST I'VE SEEN THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE AND WELLNESS --
TO PATIENTS INCREASE BUT THAT
BEING SAID I FIND IT ALSO
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO DO
BECAUSE I HAVE TO REGULARLY RUN
MY STORE BY MYSELF.
THAT MEANS THAT IF I HAVE TO
LEAVE THE STORE FOR ANY ANY
REASON TO GO TO THE BATHROOM I
DO HAVE TO CLOSE THE STORE DOWN.
ARE OR THE PHARMACY DOWN AT THE
STORE -- AS
WELL AS IT'S DIFFICULT --
TO SAFELY PROVIDE THESE EXTRA
SERVICES TO PATIENTS --
ONE OF HAVING TO PERFORM NON
DISCRETIONARY CLERICAL TASK LIKE
READING UP GROCERIES AT THE
REGISTER --
BECAUSE OF THAT I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WILL HELP TO ENSURE PATIENT
SAFETY WITH THE INCREASED ARM
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE.
TO CARE FOR THEIR PATIENTS
HEALTH AND WELLNESS SENT YOU
VEHEMENTLY ATTACKED THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE SUPPORT
NAME INFLATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SERAPH
LOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
MACHAR RIVAS CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR MOVING
THIS ISSUE PROBABLY THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT PATIENT SAFETY
ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE PODIUM AND GET ALLOW UP TO
TWO MINUTES.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
HI JENNIFER SITE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES FIRST LIKE TO
M. PROMISED MY COMMENTS BY
SAYING THAT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS OF TAKEN THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
I THINK HE IS PLANNING TO DO
THAT ENOUGH HE'S MENTIONED THAT
I'M IN WITH THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS I'M BOTH
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT I WORK
WITH WILL REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION.
I AM I JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE I
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS WITH
RESPECT TO THAT --
WE APPRECIATE SENATOR STONE'S
COMMENTS ABOUT THE FACT THAT --
PHARMACISTS IN AMMAR RETAIL
PHARMACIES AND PROVIDE A VERY
IMPORTANT AND HAVE A VERY
IMPORTANT POSITION AND ARE
WORKING A LOT WITH PATIENTS IN
NEED --
PLENTY OF TIME TO SUPPORT TO DO
THAT OF WHAT WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WILL CONTINUE TO TO RAISE
WITH THIS COMMITTEE WITH THE
SPONSORS AND WITH THE AUTHOR.
IS THAT WE FEEL THAT THIS BILL --
PROMPT SELLS HALF OF THAT
PROBLEM AND WE VERY MUCH SUPPORT
SUPPORTING OUR PHARMACISTS AND
HAVING THE STAFF AVAILABLE TO DO
THAT THAT'S WHY WE WANT TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY OR AT
LEAST ON REMAIN NEUTRAL.
BASED ON THE AMENDMENTS --
BUT CALIFORNIA HAS THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE RATIO OF PHARMACISTS
TO PHARMACY TECHNICIAN IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S ONE TO ONE AND
NO OTHER STATE HAS THAT THE
AVERAGE IN THE IN THE U. S. IS
WONDERFUL WORK.
AND SO WE'RE HEARING SENATOR
STONE IN THEIR INABILITY TO DO
MORE WITH PATIENTS DO MORE WITH
RESPECT TO THEIR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE THEY CAN'T DO THAT
UNLESS THEY HAVE MORE PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS TO HELP THEM DO
THEIR JOB SO.
WE VERY MUCH --
ENCOURAGED ON THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US ON THIS ISSUE AND HOPE
WE CAN COME BACK NEXT SESSION A
WITH A SOLUTION TO THE OTHER
PART OF THE PROBLEM THAT WE
BELIEVE IS THERE.
POUNDS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST ON KEPT HE WITH MCCUE KEPT
CAN ASSOCIATE SOMEHOW THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR I
TAKEN THE AMENDMENTS ON THAT THE
COMMITTEE OF UP FOURTH AND OUT
WITHOUT.
A RESPECTFULLY APPRECIATIVELY
REMOVE OPPOSITION AS WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHICH IN TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEE EV ASSEMBLY WOMAN A YEAH I
JUST SERVICES BEEN ABOUT
INTERESTING BILL FOR FOR ME JUST
BECAUSE I'VE SANTA BMP SINCE
I'VE.
STARTED IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
AS WE'VE ALL SAT HERE WE'VE SEEN
SCOPE ISSUES EXPANDING AND ON
THE BEEN SOME OF THE BIGGEST
FIGHTS AND SOME OF THE BIGGEST
DISCUSSIONS AND POLICY ISSUES AT
THAT WE STRUGGLED WITH.
A AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING
NOW ALSO IS OUR THE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF WHAT COMES WHEN
WE EXPAND SCOPE AND THEN STILL
HAVE TO MAINTAIN PATIENT SAFETY
AND A AND THEN STORES SEEM TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME KIND OF
PROFIT.
UP AYE CHOOSES TO GO TO A SMALL
MOM AND POP ONE WHEN I GOING TO
THE CHAINS OF IT YOU KNOW AND I
AND I SEE THE LINES.
BUT I MEAN I APPRECIATE THE
NUMBERS ARE SHOWING BUT I'VE
NEVER SEEN A PHARMACIST THERE BY
THEMSELVES THEY THINK IT'S JUST
IT'S A IT'S A BAD MODEL BECAUSE
THEN THEY'RE LOSING BUSINESS
WANTS TO LONG A LOT OF PEOPLE
JUST WALK OUT.
I AM SO I THINK IT'S PASSING I
THINK WE NEED TO STILL CONTINUE
TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING ON THIS
KINDA.
THORNY ISSUE YOU'RE ALL ABOUT
DRUGS TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CAN YOU MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NO DISH NO QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS OF
TIMES AND WE ARE STUCK WITH WHAT
I'VE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
WIENER AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOU IN
YOUR OFFICE.
AND THIS DOES ENJOYING AYE
RECOMMENDATION WE NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
MISSION THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A
SECOND COMMITTEE SIXTY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE LOW AYE
BROUGH.
ARAMBULA BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE FONG AYE GIPSON
[inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN BERMAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I'M OVERLOOKING
[inaudible]
AND TING.
THE BILL HAS THIRTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FRACTURE
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY NOW WE'RE READY FOR A
SENATOR HILL.
FELLOW BMP CHAIR WELCOME A
CENTER HERE WE GO HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROCEED WOULD YOU LIKE A
FARMER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AND YOU
SO THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AS HE FOURTEEN FORTY
EIGHT SURE HELP PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT WHEN YOU ARE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AS YOU KNOW
MANY OF US COME AND STAND BEFORE
A COMMITTEE AND WE THANK THE
CHAIR AND WE THANK.
THEIR STAFF.
I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW HOW MUCH
I REALLY REALLY REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR.
AND HIS STAFF OF FOR THE
OUTSTANDING WORK THAT THEY
PROVIDED ON THE BILL'S AT ALL BE
PRESENTING TODAY.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY ON THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE.
AS CHAIR AND STAFF FROM BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS IN THE SENATE
AND THAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP IS
OUTSTANDING AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU BECAUSE IT ALL STARTS AT THE
TOP.
AND APPRECIATED MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THAT IN YOUR
WONDERFUL STAFF SO THANK YOU --
SP --
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT IS THE
PATIENTS RIGHT TWO KNOW ACT OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT REQUIRES THAT
PHYSICIANS DISCIPLINED BY THE
REGULATORY BOARD FOR THE
FOLLOWING FOUR CATEGORIES OF
MISCONDUCT.
WILL HAVE TO NOTIFY THEIR
PATIENTS PRIOR TO THEIR VISIT.
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT WITH A PATIENT.
DRUG ABUSE THAT CAN HARM
PATIENTS CRIMINAL CONVICTION
INVOLVING HARM TO PATIENTS.
AND INAPPROPRIATE PRESCRIBING
RESULTING IN PATIENT HARM.
PATIENTS WILL FINALLY BE GIVEN
INFORMATION THAT'S ALREADY
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE SO THEY CAN
MAKE.
AN INFORMED DECISION ABOUT THEIR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
CURRENTLY DOCTORS HAVE TO NOTIFY
THEIR INSURER AND THEIR HOSPITAL
OR CLINIC ABOUT THEIR PROBATION
STATUS.
PATIENTS RECEIVE NOTICE THEY ARE
LEFT IN THE DARK AND SUSCEPTIBLE
TO FUTURE ABUSE.
A STUDY BY THE CALIFORNIA
RESEARCH BUREAU.
FOUND THAT DOCTORS WHO ENGAGE IN
MISCONDUCT ARE 30% MORE LIKELY
TO RE OFFEND.
THE MEDICAL BOARD PROVOKES THE
LICENSES OF ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
EIGHT DOCTORS EACH YEAR FOR
MISCONDUCT.
BUT THEY ALSO NEGOTIATE
PROBATION WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FOUR DOCTORS WHICH
ALLOWS THEM TO KEEP PRACTICING.
THIS WILL BE THIS BILL WILL MAKE
SURE THAT PAY PATIENTS ARE FULLY
INFORMED WHEN THEY SEE THEIR
DOCTORS WHO ARE ON PROBATION.
I HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER READY.
GOOD MORNING I THINK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
AYE TO SHARE MY STORY.
I SICK BEFORE YOU TODAY WITH THE
HEAVY BUT HOPEFUL HEART.
I WOULD HAVE AVOIDED BEING
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT IF THERE
WAS A PATIENT'S RIGHT TO KNOW
BILL AVAILABLE.
I AM LABELED A VICTIM.
ALTHOUGH I FEEL MOST LIKE A
SURVIVOR.
MANY WILL SAY.
BUT YOU DIDN'T CHEAT DEATH.
HOWEVER I FEEL I DID.
MY CHARACTER WAS ATTACKED AND MY
COGNITIVE AWARENESS WAS SEVERED.
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO ALLOW ANOTHER
PATIENT. TO GAIN THE TITLE I
WOULD WILLINGLY EARNED.
ALL I ASK IS THAT YOU PROVIDE
THE KNOWLEDGE.
I'M TIFFANY THOMAS LOPEZ.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GINA AND
PLAN I AM ONE OF OVER THREE
HUNDRED WOMEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
BY OUR NATIONAL TEAM DOCTOR LEHR
NASSER.
BEING A VICTIM OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
IS NOT A CHOICE I WOULDN'T WISH
IT ON MY WORST ENEMY.
IS A SAD TRUTH THAT HAS LASTING
EFFECTS --
AND WILL TAKE YEARS TO HEAL.
I AM AN UNFORTUNATE EXAMPLE OF
WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN BILLS LIKE
THIS ARE NOT PUT IN PLACE AS A
VICTIM OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
FROM MY DOCTOR I THINK IT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT AS A PATIENT
THAT YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW
IF YOUR DOCTOR IS HARM PATIENTS
IN THE PAST.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ENCOURAGE AND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL S. B..
ONE FOUR FOUR EIGHT TRANSPARENCY
WHEN IT COMES TO PATIENT DOCTOR
RELATIONSHIP IS VITAL.
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE FOR THEMSELVES WHAT THEY
WANT TO BE TREATED BY DOCTOR
THAT'S PREPARATION.
I KNOW WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO NOT
HAVE A CHOICE MY HOPE IS THAT BY
PASSING A BILL IT WILL CALL FOR
MORE MORE DISCLOSURE EDITOR
DOCTORS FROM BETRAYING THE
PATIENT TRUST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY NAME IS JAMIE ANSWER AND THEN
FIRST LIKE TO THING CENTER JAIL
AND HAVING LOW IN THE ASSEMBLY
FOR MOVING US FORWARD.
I AM TO YOU IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- I
WAS.
AS WELL AS TIFFANY ENGINE AT A
VICTIM OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
BY LARRY NOW SIR OVER A SPAN OF
SIX YEARS.
ON SO WE'RE JUST.
STRONGLY ENCOURAGING YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY FOR THIS BILL.
ADD TO OUR KNOWLEDGE.
AND TO LET THE PATIENT MAKE THE
CHOICE AND I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT FOR PATIENT
SAFETY IN THE FUTURE AND COULD
SAVE.
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF MORE
VICTIMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO A TO
THREE OF YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE
AND FOR COMING HERE TODAY.
AND NOW ALLOW OF ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAME INFLATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AT HOWARD AT THE CENTER
FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW AND STRONG SUPPORT AND
WITH.
GRATITUDE TO YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND SPECIAL
GRATITUDE TO SENATOR HILL WHO
HAS BEEN [inaudible]
PERSISTENT A COURAGEOUS AND
PUSHING THIS BILL FORWARD THANK
YOU ALL.
JACKIE STERN ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
ROBERT COOLEY OF REPRESENTING
THE BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC
EXAMINERS WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH OUR
CONSUMER PROTECTION MANDATE AND
WILL INSURE THAT PATIENTS.
ARE HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION AGE
THAT I'M SORRY ALL THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION WHEN CHOOSING
A HEALTHCARE PROVIDER THANK YOU.
SIMON BOLIVAR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CONSUMER WATCHDOG ONE I THINK
BOTH OF THE CHAIRS FOR THIS BILL
TO LIFT THE VEIL OF SECRECY
AROUND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
REBECCA MITCHELL ACT UNEXPECTED
MEDICINE COMMITTEE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HI JENNIFER SUMMERS OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA OR
BOARD DID HAVE A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED POSITION ON THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THIS BILL AND BOARD
STAFF TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ON THE LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY IN THIS BILL.
AM HOWEVER THIS BILL DOES NARROW
M. TO SPECIFIC CATEGORIES BUT
THEY'RE NOT EXACTLY THE SAME AS
WHAT THE BOARD REQUESTED SO.
AND WE DID WORK WITH EVERYONE ON
THE ON THE LANGUAGE AND WILL
BRING IT BACK TO OUR BOARD AND I
MEAN UNTIL I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
SINGLE ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
PODIUM.
PLEASE FEEL FREE PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
IF YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS MAKE
IT ALRIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATELY STILL IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT WHILE WE
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE MOVEMENT
THAT HAS HAPPENED ON THIS BILL
AND ALL OF THE DILIGENT WORK OF
THE AUTHOR THERE'S ONE
OUTSTANDING AMENDMENT.
REGARDING DISCLOSURE OFFELONIES
THAT INVOLVE PATIENT HARM VERSUS
MISDEMEANORS WE BELIEVE THAT THE
AMENDMENT WILL STRIKE THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
INFORMING PATIENTS IN
INTERFERING WITH PATIENT CARE.
AND WITHOUT A MOMENT I WOULD BE
ABLE TO REMOVE OPPOSITION BUT AT
THIS TIME WE WILL STICK REMAIN
OPPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WOODS IS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY WOMAN
BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU SENATOR HELL --
I HAVE SEEN VERSIONS OF THIS
ISSUE A COUPLE TIMES BUT A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO YOUR
WITNESSES.
AFTER COMING VERY MUCH A WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR ON THIS IN THIS
ISSUE AND MANY OTHERS THAT WILL.
CONTINUE TO COME UP AS WE LEARN
HOW WE AS A COMMITTEE CAN BETTER
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM PREDATORS
LIKE DOCTOR NASSER.
AND SO THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT
AND AND STAINING GAUGED AYE I'M
HAVE BUT THE QUESTION THE
COMMENT THE QUESTION IS JUST TO
THE SPECIFIC AMENDMENT THAT THE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION HAS REYES.
ARE YOU STILL IN DISCUSSIONS --
AREA THAT YOU FEEL IS WORTH
LOOKING AT IF NOT WHAT ABOUT
THAT AMENDMENT MIGHT MAKE YOU
CHOOSE TO NOT TAKE IT BOOK
THINKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER THE THE
THE THAT THE AMENDMENT THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR THEIR
OPPOSITION IS IS WRAPPED AROUND
ONE ISSUE.
ANDTHAT IS IN OUR BILL TALKS
ABOUT CRIMINAL CONVICTION
INVOLVING HARM TO PATIENTS.
UP WE CONSIDER ANY.
TYPE OF CONVICTION THAT HARMS A
PATIENT SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN
NOTIFICATION.
WITH THEY WANT IS JUST FELONY
CONVICTIONS WELL IN MANY
CONVICTIONS MAY BE A FELONY OF
OF WOULD BE CHARGES OF FELONY
AND PLAYED DOWN TO A MISDEMEANOR
AND IF I COULD GIVE YOU A COUPLE
EXAMPLES.
THAT WOULD NOT BE INCLUDED IN
THEIR DEFINITION ONE IS --
ANONYMOUS TELEPHONE CALLS PERSON
PLAYED DOWN FROM ANNOYING OR
MOLESTING A MINOR CHILD. TO TO
THAT TO ANONYMOUS TELEPHONE
CALLS BECAUSE THEY RID THE
DOCTOR WAS HARASSING AN UNDER
AGE CHILD AND PARENT.
I THINK THAT'S PATIENT HARM
POSSESSION OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION
THAT'S WHAT THE DOCTOR HAD.
WELL THAT WAS PLAYED DOWN TO A
MISDEMEANOR BUT THEY WERE GOING
TO GIVE THEY WERE GIVING THE
PATIENT THOSE SUBSTANCES THAT
WERE CONTROLLED.
A ASSAULT WAS PLAYED DOWN TO A
MISDEMEANOR.
WELL ASSAULT IT WAS ASSAULT
AGAINST A PATIENT.
A OF TRAINING CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES THROUGH FRAUD DECEIT
OR MISREPRESENTATION.
THAT WOULD BE YOU WOULDN'T THINK
THERE BE PATIENT HARM BUT THAT
OBTAINING THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES WERE GIVEN TO
PATIENTS.
L. USING A CONCEALED CAMCORDER
TO SECRETLY VIDEOTAPE A PERSON
IN A PLACE WHERE THE PERSON.
HAS A REASONABLE EXPECTATION OF
PRIVACY THAT WAS THE CHARGE OF
AS A MISDEMEANOR.
THAT WAS HARMING A PATIENT
BECAUSE THEY WERE FILMING A
PATIENT.
IN THE ROOM PETTY IN GRAND THEFT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE.
SOME SEPARATE FROM THAT BUT THEY
WERE STEALING FROM A PATIENT.
SO THAT'S WHY WE FELT THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT REGARDLESS OF FELONY
OR MISDEMEANOR.
ALL CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT SHOWS
IT INDICATES A HARM TO PATIENTS
I UNDERSTAND AND I AM I AGREE
WITH YOU THERE --
THERE ARE SO MANY MISDEMEANORS
THAT ARE --
ONES THAT I THINK PATIENTS WOULD
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT.
AND ONE IS THAT IF YOU'RE A
MANDATED REPORTER AND YOU KNEW
ABOUT THE CSUS ARE YOU SUSPECTED
POTENTIAL ABUSE OF SOMEONE
YOU'RE MANDATED TO TELL --
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND IF YOU DON'T
IT'S A MISDEMEANOR AND A FINE OF
THOUSAND DOLLARS BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY PERTINENT
TO THE LARRY NASSER CASON.
AND OTHER CASES --
IN AYE I'M IS SUPPORT THIS AND
AND I THINK ONE OF THINGS I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO SEE IS THAT.
YOU HAVE MADE IT A MUCH MORE
NARROW PROVISION THAT WHAT PRIOR
EFFORTS TO DISCLOSE TO PATIENTS
PROBATION STATUS HAVE BEEN.
NOT ONLY SUBJECT MATTER LIKE
POTENTIAL OF WE WHICH ARE
PRACTICES AND POTENTIAL PATIENT
HARM AS OPPOSED TO SOMETIMES --
A PERSON TO BE PUT ON PROBATION
IN DIFFERENT FIELDS OF PRACTICE
BECAUSE THEY'RE BACK ON THEIR
TAXES OR THEY HAVE --
SPOUSAL SUPPORT OBVIOUSLY THINK
THOSE ARE BAD THINGS BUT VERY IF
A PROPOSED OUT PROVOKES SAYS
SENTIMENT IT --
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO CARE FOR
NATION MIGHT HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE PRACTICE AND SCOPES
TIME I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE
MADE IT MORE NARROW IN THAT
RESPECT.
AND SECONDLY THAT THE PROVISION.
THAT MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS AN
INDIVIDUAL CONVERSATION BETWEEN
THE PATIENT AND THE DOCTOR.
AB PRIOR EFFORTS TO JUST PAINT A
BROAD BRUSH AND SEE IF YOU'RE ON
PROBATION AFTER.
POSTED IN THIS WAY AND IT COULD
BE ABOUT SOMETHING TOTALLY
UNRELATED DIDN'T HELP THAT
CONVERSATION BETWEEN A DOCTOR
AND A PATIENT WHERE THE PATIENT
CAN BE EMPOWERED TO MAKE THE
DECISION.
OKAY THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
RELEVANT TO WHETHER OR NOT I I
WANT TO CONTINUE TO SEE THIS
POSITION OR I UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE.
I STILL WANT TO SEE THIS
POSITION AND I APPRECIATE THAT --
IT'S NOT PERFECT I THINK THERE
ARE SOME YOU KNOW IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN OFTEN HAVE PERFECT BILLS
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU ARE
TENACIOUS ABOUT THIS AND FOCUSED
ON THESE TWO AREAS WHERE.
PRIOR EFFORTS HAVE BEEN TOO
BROAD AND HAVE ACTUALLY I THINK
UNDERMINES.
THE INFORMATION THAT'S VALUABLE
GOING TO A PATIENT SO I'M
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AND I I HOPE
IT GOES FORWARD I I DO OF COURSE
ALWAYS ENCOURAGED HIM. TO WORK
WITH THOSE WHO ARE MOST AFFECTED
IN THE PHYSICIAN'S PRACTICE BY
THE CONCERNS --
IF IF THERE'S A WAY TO REACH --
ADDITIONAL AGREEMENT ON THE
SCOPE OF HOW YOU DEFINE THIS
CONVICTIONS OR VOTE BUT IS MOST
USEFUL FOR PATIENTS TO HAVE --
I'D STRONGLY ENCOURAGE CONTINUE
TO DO THAT THANK YOU --
FOR MAKING THOSE CHANGES AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM CONSUMERS AT THIS
TIME CENTER TO HELP YOU WISH TO
CLOSE AYE.
IP APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
AND I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT --
AND WE DID THERE ARE THE BILL
CONSIDERABLY IN IN.
NARRATIVE WITH THE FOCUS OF
PATIENT HARM.
THAT REALLY IS THE CRITERION
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND THE
THAT AND WHAT REALLY MADE THE
DIFFERENCE IT.
I MEAN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE DU
Y..
IF IF IF A PHYSICIAN WERE TO GET
A D. WHY THAT IS SERIOUS.
THAT IS REPORTABLE TO THE TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD.
BUT THAT DIDN'T IN LESS THAT DO
YOU AYE AFFECTED A PATIENT IT
SHOULD NOT BE PART OF THE
DISCLOSURE.
A AND THAT'S HOW WE WE
INTERPRETED AND THAT'S HOW WE
KNOW WHAT KIND OF FOCUSED DID
AND THE OF FUNNELED VIA THE
APPROACH FOR DIRECTLY PATIENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR MEMBERS AND
AGAIN THANK YOU.
TO A TWO YEAR CHAIR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AND THAT AND
YOUR STAFF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR AND I
WANT TO REAFFIRM THEIR
COMMITMENT AND ONGOING
COMMUNICATIONS WITH NOT ONLY
WITH OUR OFFICES BUT DIRECTLY
FROM ARE SENATE COUNTERPARTS.
ON ENSURING THAT THAT CONSUMER
PROTECTION IS THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY AND WE VERY MUCH SHARE
THAT.
MEANS INSURING THAT WE CAN HAVE
AS MANY SO WITH THAT SAID I'M A
PROUD CLOTH AND THAT YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TENACITY IN YOUR
PASSION AGAIN TO THE WITNESSES
WHO HAVE COME.
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COURAGE AS WELL HOW WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
IT'S BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
AT THIS IT DOES AGAIN AND ENJOY
IT I RECOGNITION FROM THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOST ES DE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I LOW I BROKE.
ARAMBULA BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE FONG AYE GIPSON
[inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
TING.
THE BILL HAS TEN AYE VOTES WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR PLEASE REMIND.
MAY WE MOVE TO SB SEVEN TWENTY
ONE I DO HAVE A WITNESS FOR THAT
WITH THE SP SEVEN TWENTY ONE A
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO S. B. SEVEN TWENTY ONE
PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT APARTMENT
BUILDINGS CONDOS AND H. AWAYS --
CONDOS THAT ARE THREE STORIES
NOT H. ALWAYS ANY LONGER ARE
HIGHER THAN.
OR HIGHER HAVE 15% OF THEIR
BALCONIES INSPECTED EVERY SIX
YEARS.
BUILDING OWNERS WOULD HAVE FOUR
MONTHS TO GET A PERMIT IN SIX
MONTHS TO MAKE REPAIRS.
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE THAT HAS
KILLED PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IF ANY OF YOU HAVE GONE ON
THE LEGISLATIVE TRIP TO IRELAND
IN RECENT YEARS YOU'VE LIKELY
MET.
WITH THE FAMILIES CHILDREN WERE
KILLED WHEN A BALCONY COLLAPSED
IN BERKELEY IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN ALSO IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN A STAIRWELL IN AN
APARTMENT BUILDING IN THE CITY
OF FOLSOM COLLAPSED KILLING A
POT THE KALPOE A MASTER'S
STUDENT.
WHO WAS VISITING HIS FRIEND WE
CAN PREVENT THESE TRAGEDIES WITH
REASONABLE STATEWIDE INSPECTION
AND REPAIR STANDARDS I SPENT THE
LAST YEAR NEGOTIATING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS?
THAT OUT THAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REMOVE OPPOSITION FROM THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
DEPARTMENT ASSOCIATION THE
COMMUNITY MANAGER SAYS
ASSOCIATION AND LOCAL BUILDING
OFFICIALS THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTION BILL.
THAT SUPPORTED BY THE CENTER FOR
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA THE CITY
BERKELEY AND THE COUNSEL GENERAL
OF IRELAND.
I ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS REMOVE
REMOVING SECTION TWO FROM THE
BILL DEALING WITH H. AWAYS.
THERE IN A UNIQUE SITUATION
SINCE THEY DO EXTERIOR VISUAL
INSPECTIONS EVERY THREE YEARS.
BUT DON'T USE ANY DEVICE OR
METHODS TO OBTAIN A DIRECT
VISUAL INSPECTION FOR BALCONIES
INDEX.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS OVER THE
THE INTERIM AS WE EXPLORE WAYS
TO IMPROVE THEIR EXISTING.
VISUAL INSPECTION PROGRAM TO
ENSURE THE DECKS AND BALCONIES
ARE SAFE I DO HAVE WITNESSES
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION MAY SHARE THAT YOU
HAVE THE EXIT THAT THEY
COMMITTEE MEN'S IS THAT RIGHT
YES WONDERFUL MINUTES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH --
WELCOME UP TO THREE MINUTES FOR
A WOODS IS IN SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS AMANDA DONAHOE AND
I AND THE SISTER OF ASHLEY
DONAHOE AND COUSIN OF BOLIVIA
BURKE WHO WERE KILLED IN THE
BERKELEY BALCONY CLAPS THREE
YEARS AGO LAST SATURDAY.
THE BALCONY HAD STRUCTURAL FLAWS
ESSENTIALLY TURNING IT INTO DRY
ROCK COVERED IN STUCCO.
SOMETHING NO ONE WOULD WALK OUT
ON IF THEY WERE AWARE.
THIS PREVENTABLE STRUCTURAL FLAW
KILLED MY SISTER MY COUSIN AND
FOUR OF THEIR FRIENDS.
AS WELL AS SEVERELY INJURING
SEVERAL OTHERS.
THIS BALCONY COLLAPSE IS NOT AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE
HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF OTHER
BALCONY IN DEBT COLLAPSES
INCLUDING WHEN IT OPENED IN MAY
OF THIS YEAR COST BY DRY ROT.
AS WELL AS ONES IN SANTA BARBARA
IN FOLSOM WHICH CAUSED
PREVENTABLE INJURIES AND LOSS OF
LIFE.
THE WEEK BEFORE THE COLLAPSE
ASHLEY OLIVIA AND HUMOR WERE AT
MY HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION.
IT WAS SUCH A HAPPY DAY WAY JUST
IMER UP IN MY CAP AND GOWN
BECAUSE SHE WAS SO EXCITED TO
SEE OF REAL LIFE.
AMERICAN I SCHOOL GRADUATION.
IT WAS EVEN READ JUST LIKE IN
HIGH SCHOOL MUSICAL SHE SAID.
LOOKING BACK YOU CAN NOW SEE
THEY WERE DISTRACTING ME FROM MY
NERVES BUT SPEAKING LATER THAT
DAY.
BECAUSE THEY WERE GOOD THAT WAY.
IT'S HARD TO LOOK BACK AT THE
PICTURES NOW SEEING THEIR
SMILING FACES.
MINE SURROUNDED BY THREE PEOPLE
DEAR TO ME WHO ARE NO LONGER
WITH US.
THE NIGHT OF THE COLLAPSE I WENT
TO BERKELEY WITH MY PARENTS.
AT SEVENTEEN I SAW MY OLDER
SISTER DEAD ON THE GROUND AN
OUTFIT I MYSELF GESTURE IN JUST
HOURS BEFORE.
WHEN SHE BEG ME TO LET HER
BORROW MY BRAND NEW TOP?
ALONG WITH MY COUSIN BOLIVIA
HEMER AND THEIR FRIENDS.
I WENT TO IRELAND TO MAKE HAS
AND OLIVIA AND OTHER STUDENTS
FUNERALS.
I SPENT A WEEK GOING TO FUNERALS
IN SOME CASES THERE EVEN TO A
DAY.
I HAVE TO LIVE THE REST OF MY
LIFE WITHOUT MY SISTER WHO WAS
NOT ONLY A SISTER BUT MY BEST
FRIEND.
I AM NOW AN ONLY CHILD IN THIS
COUNTRY THE ONLY NATURAL BORN
AMERICAN IN MY ENTIRE FAMILY.
WHAT I AM TRYING TO CAN SAY HERE
IS THAT MY SISTER MY COUSIN AND
THEIR FRIENDS ARE NOT JUST
STATISTICS TO BE LANE BEFORE YOU?
BUT ACTUAL PEOPLE WITH HOPES
GOALS AND ASPIRATIONS.
WHICH WERE CUT TRAGICALLY SHORT.
THERE IS A HUMAN COST. TO
ALLOWING THE LOSS TO CONTINUE TO
EXIST IN THE WAY THEY DO TODAY.
AND I AM HERE BEFORE YOU TO ASK
FOR CHANGE.
IT IS YOUR DUTY AS LEGISLATORS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
PROTECT THE LIVES AND WELL BEING
OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
PLEASE PASS SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
TO PREVENT FUTURE DEATHS AND
PROTECT ALL OF US THANK YOU.
BUT YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
ALSO WESTERN BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF BERKELEY WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS --
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
PREVENT TRAGEDIES SUCH AS THIS
FROM HAPPENING ANYWHERE IN THE
FUTURE --
AND WE OR DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHICH SPEAK.
IT DOESN'T PUT IN HERE.
PSYCHIC COMMITTEE MEMBER AM MY
NAME IS JOHN CALLAHAN OF THE
VICE CONSUL OF ART AND THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES I'M I JUST
WANNA SAY THAT THE CONSULATE
GENERAL OF IRELAND AND INDEED
THE GOVERNMENT OF IRELAND ARE
FOLLOWING THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION CLOSELY.
AND WE WE CONTINUE TO MOURN THE
LOSS OF THE FIVE IRISH AND ONE
IRISH AMERICAN STUDENTS WHO LOST
THEIR LIVES AND ALSO THE SEVEN
IRISH SAYS STUDENTS WHO USES AND
LIFE CHANGING INJURIES.
AND WE COMMEND THE DUGGAR FAMILY
AND SENATOR HELL FOR THE WORK WE
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR THOSE
OF YOU DON'T KNOW ME MY NAME IS
JACKIE DUNHILL.
AND MY LIFE WAS CHANGED FOREVER
ON JUNE SIXTEENTH.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN I LOST MY
PRESENT MY PAST.
I'M MY FUTURE BUT I LOST MY
DAUGHTER ASHLEY.
WHEN THE BALCONY SHE WAS
STANDING ON COLLAPSED?
I NEVER GET MY DAUGHTER BACK.
WE TIME PROTECTOR KIDS WE TRY TO
TEACH THEM RIGHT FROM WRONG.
HOW MANY OF YOU WOULD EVER THINK
TO TELL YOUR KIDS DON'T STEP OUT
ON THE BALCONY?
I KNOW I DIDN'T.
IF THE BALCONY BEEN INSPECTED BY
LICENSE INSPECTOR OUR KIDS COULD
BE ALIVE TODAY.
ASHLEY AND THE OTHER STUDENTS
SHOULD BE HERE.
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED A
WE NEVER WANT TO SEE ANOTHER
FAMILY GO TO THE HELL WHAT WE'VE
BEEN TRUE OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS.
THE PARENTS OF THE FIVE OTHER
VICTIMS WERE KILLED WILL NEVER
GET TO SEE THEIR KIDS AGAIN.
THE IRISH PARENTS SEND THEIR
SONS AND DAUGHTERS. TO BE S. FOR
J. ONE SUMMER EXPERIENCE CUT IN
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA RETURNED THEM IN A
BOX FIVE CONFERENCE WENT BACK TO
ART.
THEATER SEVEN INJURED KIDS WILL
NEVER BE THE SAME AND SO MANY
LIVES WERE CHANGED.
THIS BILL REQUIRES ABOUT PLEASE
BE INSPECTED AND ARE SAFE ENOUGH
TO COAT FOR ME I'D LIKE TO SEE
AS JERRY HEALTH MENTIONED A FEW
MOMENTS AGO.
THAT ALL BALCONIES NOT JUST
APARTMENT BUILDINGS WITH THREE
OR MORE MULTI DWELLINGS.
I WANT YOU TO THINK IF THIS WAS
YOUR CHILD OR A MEMBER OF YOUR
FAMILY HOW WOULD YOU FEEL.
HOW MANY MORE BALCONIES?
AYE READY TO FALL DOWN THE STATE
CALIFORNIA.
THE BOOK BERKELEY DEBT.
THE CHANGES THEY MADE AFTER
[inaudible]
THE TRAGEDY.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE WAS BURKE IS
A SMALL CITY IN CALIFORNIA?
THEY INSPECTED. TWO THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX BALCONIES
AFTER TO JIM BERKELEY BALCONY
COLLAPSE.
AND APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
TO THEM HAD ISSUES THAT 18%
THINK ABOUT 18% LITTLE BERKELEY
POP BERKELEY ON THE MAP IN
CALIFORNIA A BUT THOSE
PERCENTAGES IN A TANK AND MANY
MORE THOSE BALCONIES ARE READY
TO COME DOWN.
THIS IS A SMALL PRICE TO PAY FOR
THIS BILL. FOR A LIFE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEN
APARTMENTS CONDO OWNERS IF THE
ONE BALCONIES ON THE BUILDINGS.
THEY NEED TO PAY TO GET THEM
PROPERLY INSPECTED.
I'M SPEAKING OUT TODAY. FOR
THOSE WHO NO LONGER HAVE A VOICE.
MY NIECE LIBBY BURKE FOREVER
TWENTY ONE ON CULLIGAN FOREVER
TWENTY ONE NICK LIKE SHUSTER
FOREVER TWENTY ONE LOCUM MILLER
FOREVER TWENTY ONE ANYMORE WATCH
FOREVER.
TWENTY ONE A MY BELOVED DAUGHTER
ACTUALLY DONE WHO WHO HAD JUST
TURNED.
TWENTY TWO I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
I LET THEIR DEATHS NOT BE IN
VAIN.
BECAUSE IF SOMEONE ELSE HAD DONE
THE RIGHT TING WAY BACK THEN.
THREE YEARS AGO AND WAS NO
SECRET SETTLEMENTS.
AND THE WAS PROPER INSPECTIONS.
I'M THE CONSTRUCTION BOARD KNEW
ABOUT AS WELL OF THE PREVIOUS
BALCONY ISSUES.
OUR KIDS COULD BE ALIVE TODAY.
AND ONE MORE THING I'M GOING TO
JUST LEAVE YOU WISH IN THIS DAY
AND AGE.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
CALIFORNIA BILLS CANTILEVER
BALCONIES. FIFTY FEET ABOVE
GROUND LEVEL.
MADE OUT OF WOOD.
WRAPPED IN STUCCO.
WITH NO TIES BACK TO THE
BUILDING.
BUT NEVER HAVE TO BE INSPECTED.
AND THEY EXPECT THEM TO LAST A
LIFETIME.
SO FOR EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU
I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT THIS
EVERY TIME YOU STEP OUT ON THE
BALCONY.
AND HOPEFULLY IT WON'T BE OUR
LAST STEP YOU TAKE.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME
[inaudible]
I APPRECIATE.
I LET'S MAKE CALIFORNIA A SAFER
PLACE TO LIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
VERSION IS PICKING SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
PODIUM IF YOU CAN KIND OF MAKE
SOME ROOM.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY --
THANK YOU MATTER THAT MISTER
CHAIR.
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE ON RUN
KINGSTON I REPRESENT FOR
REGIONAL APARTMENT ASSOCIATIONS.
EAST BAY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION.
PARTICIPATION ORANGE COUNTY.
NORTH VALLEY APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND PART MISSUS
USUALLY ORANGE COUNTY.
SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OF THIS
BILL WE HAVE MET WITH THE AUTHOR --
HIS STAFF ON INNUMERABLE
OCCASIONS.
I WE HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
EVEN TO SPEAK WITH YOUR STAFF AT
GREAT LENGTH MISTER CHAIRMAN --
ABOUT OUR SPECIFIC CONCERNS
THERE NOT UNRESOLVABLE.
BUT THEY'RE VERY VERY IMPORTANT.
THERE'S NO QUESTION IN MY MIND.
SENSELESS DEATH IS SENSELESS
DEATH WHETHER YOU FALL OFF A
BALCONY OR ANY OTHER PURPOSE.
WE ARE NOT WE ARE NOT LOOKING AT
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
PRACTICALITY OF IMPLEMENTING.
AND MAKING SENSE OF A STATEWIDE
MANDATORY INSPECTION PROGRAM.
OF ALL RESIDENTIAL RENTAL UNITS
I PERSONALLY DON'T SEE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A CONDOMINIUM
UNIT THAT IS FIVE STORIES TALL
OR AN APARTMENT THAT IS FIVE
STORIES TALL THAT HASSA.
DECKED BALCONY A PORCH --
AND BUT THAT'S AND THAT'S A
DISCUSSION OF ANOTHER DAY.
THERE FIVE ISSUES I WANT TO
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN RESOLVED THAT ARE VERY
VERY MATERIAL AND VERY
SUBSTANTIVE [inaudible]
FIRST -- HAD.
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO DIRECTOR
UNIT UNDER SPECIFIC LAW.
I WE HAVE ACCESS TO A RENTAL
UNIT TO SHOW UP FOR SALE FOR
LEAKS --
EVEN -- TO
MAINTAIN BUT NOT TO INSPECT IS A
SHORTCOMING WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
IN THAT THIS BILL SHOULD DO
THEIR SECOND.
THIS IS A VERY VERY BIG ISSUE
THE BILL SAYS THE INSPECTION IS
TO BE DONE ON 15% OF UNIT.
I GUESS TO BE INSPECTED --
OR TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
INSPECTOR.
AND OF THE 15% BUT WHEN THE
INSPECTOR IS LOOKING AT THE DARK
FALCON ES THE PORCH.
WHERE THAT ATTACH IS TO THE WALL?
EVERY INSPECTOR HAVING ANY
QUALITY AND ANY --
EDUCATION WILL.
WILL SAY THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
THE REPORT BECAUSE THAT.
SPECTOR'S GOT TO KNOW HOW THE
DECKED THE BALCONY THE PORCH IS
ATTACHED TO THE WALL IS IT SAFE
TO AS BY THE PREVIOUS WITNESS
POINTED OUT.
ABOUT --
WOOD FRAME BUILDINGS ETCETERA.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INVASIVE NATURE OF V. INSPECTION
IN THE INSPECTIONS WILL CALL FOR
FURTHER --
FURTHER INVASIVECAN ADD
DESTRUCTIVE TECHNIQUES.
I TO MAKE THIS DETERMINATION WE
BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD BE ONLY
BASED ON EVIDENCE ON THE OUTSIDE
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG.
ON THE INSIDE OF THE WALL.
THREE THERE'S NO APPEAL TO THIS --
TO THIS BILL.
INSPECTOR GUM OPINES HERE'S THE
REPORT WE HAVE NO RIGHT TO
APPEAL OR JUST YOU [inaudible]
WHAT?
WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE VERY
SPECIFICALLY THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IDENTIFIED BY ANY?
OF THE INSPECTION ITEMS.
THERE'S ALWAYS A RIGHT TO APPEAL
BUT THIS BILL DOESN'T --
ADDRESS IT AS YET [inaudible]
NEXT -- WE
HAVE TO DISCLOSE EVERY
INSPECTION THAT IS BUT BEEN DONE
IN ETERNITY IT SAYS FOR SIX
YEARS BUT THEN IT.
ARE OR TWO SIX YEAR INSPECTION
CYCLES.
BUT WHAT REALLY SHOULD HAPPEN.
IS THAT IT SHOULD BE FOR ONE
CYCLE AND LETS OF VALUE WAITED
WHAT WE OF WEEK RESPECTFULLY IF
REQUESTED.
IS BECAUSE THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME.
EVER STATEWIDE MANDATORY
INSPECTION OF ALL THESE TAX.
BALCONIES PORCHES AND EVERYONE'S
DISTRICTS --
THAT.
WE SHOULD COME BACK AND EVALUATE.
IF THE HOW EFFECTIVE --
THE TERMS OF MISTER HILLS BILL
IS.
AND FINALLY [inaudible]
THE WHEN THE INSPECTION.
IS OPINED AND IT'S WRITTEN NOW.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE SOLD A
HOUSE OR PROPERTY?
WITH THE AIR CONDITIONERS FIX.
THE OVEN IS FIXED.
EVERYTHING IS FIXED DO YOU
DISCLOSE DO YOU HAVE AN
AFFIRMATIVE DUTY. TO DISCLOSE
THAT TO A BUYER NO BECAUSE IT'S
NOT BROKEN ANYMORE IT'S BEEN
REPAIRED IT'S BEEN REPLACED.
YET THIS BILL ENVISIONS.
THAT THE PREVIOUS INSPECTIONS
THERE HAVE IDENTIFIED A PROBLEM.
EVEN THOUGH THEY'VE BEEN
CORRECTED YOU STILL HAVE TO
DISCLOSE THIS IS A MATERIAL
DEPARTURE.
FROM --
DISCLOSURE OBLIGATION FROM A
SELLER TO A BUYER I'VE NOT SEEN
THAT EVER IN OF REAL PROPERTY.
IT'S CLOSE UNLESS.
THE BUYER SAYS. TO MISTER MULLIN
MISTER MULLIN.
AT HAVE YOU EVER REPLACE THE AIR
CONDITIONER V. EVER REPLACE THIS
REVIEW REPAIR THE TACK YOU HAVE
AN AFFIRMATIVE DUTY.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE AN
AFFIRMATIVE DUTY AT ALL.
IF YOU FIXED IT.
EXCEPT THIS BILL WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT'S PERTINENT TO THAT
TRANSACTION UNLESS ASKED BY A
UMPIRE IF THERE IS A PROBLEM.
OR IF THERE --
IF SOMETHING HAS BEEN CORRECTED
DURING THE TERM OF OWNERSHIP AND
FOR THAT THESE THINGS ARE
RESOLVABLE.
BUT THIRD THEY'VE NOT BEEN
APPROACHED HERE AND THAT'S WHY
I'M TRYING TO SAY TO YOU.
IS THE RIGHT TO APPEAL THE RIGHT.
GOING TO INSPECT THE RIGHT TO
DISPUTE --
AND THINGS OF THIS NATURE THAT
WE'VE OUTLINED WE BELIEVE --
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN THIS
BILL IN ORDER FOR IT TO BE
WORKABLE.
AN ACCEPTABLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOW AND HE JUST ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION SINCE
INSTITUTE AND CALIFORNIA LEGAL
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
I AM HAPPY TO SAY THAT WITH THE
ACCEPTANCE OF THEIR COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WE ARE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION WE APPRECIATE.
THAT CHAIR STAFF AND ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK
ON THIS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU.
IN THE INTERIM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IS NOW.
TAKING THIS CONVERSATION BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
OR SUB ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN.
I THINK IT IS A BILL THE MOVED.
NOT YET NOT MOVE THE BILL --
THANK YOU I JUST READ THAT I
THINK THE THIS IS THE DAY OF
FIVE TENACIOUS SENATOR HILL.
SAID HER THROUGH MULTIPLE YEARS
AS YOU'VE COME BORDER THINGS AND
I ALSO SET A ROOM IN IRELAND --
WITH THE MULTIPLE FAMILY MEMBERS
AND THEIR GRIEF WAS PALPABLE AND
WE HAD TO TRY TO EXPLAIN WHY WE
COULDN'T.
HADN'T BEEN SUCCESSFUL YET IN
BEING ABLE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS.
SO WHILE WE COULDN'T.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER BECAUSE HE
OPPOSITION WAS. TO TO RIGOROUS I
AM GLAD THAT WE'VE FINALLY BEEN
ABLE.
TO A TO TO DO THIS AND I CAN
TELL YOU IF YOU'RE IN IRELAND
AND MENTION BERKELEY BERKELEY IN
BALCONIES THE WHOLE THE WHOLE
COUNTRY KNOWS WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK.
IN AGAIN.
OUR OUR CONDOLENCES AND THOUGHTS
WITH THE FAMILIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN.
THANK YOU MISS MISTER CHAIR --
AND LIKE MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EGGMAN I WAS IN THE ROOM
MEETING WITH THE FAMILIES IN
DUBLIN WHO WERE SO.
AFFECTED BY THIS AND THAT PLEDGE
TO ACT AS A STATE.
AND SENATOR HELL I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
OFF AND AND YOUR TENACITY IN THE
WORDS OF MY COLLEAGUE SEEKING
THIS BILL THROUGH.
AND PLEASED TO SUPPORT AND
GRATEFUL TO WITH THE FAMILIES
FOR THEIR BRAVERY.
AND THEIR TESTIMONY AND FOR A
COMPELLING OF ALL OF US TO ACT.
OUGHT TO ADDRESS THAT SITUATION
SO.
GRATEFUL TO YOU SENATOR AND TO
THE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PRO.
THANK YOU SHARE SUTTER HEALTH
THANKS FOR CONTINUING TO WORK ON
THIS --
FAMILIES ON SORRY YOU HAVE TO BE
LIVED US --
THROUGH THIS BILL BUT AS OUR
COLLEAGUE SAID WE DID SET FOR
NINETY MINUTES IN DUBLIN WITH
FAMILIES.
AND HURT THEIR HEART WRENCHING
STORIES.
AND DONE PROMISE THAT WE WOULD
ACT.
BUT THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING
YOUR EFFORT ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS DO ONE THING I
WOULD ASK YOU SAID IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT SHOULD
CONTINUE THE INTERN TO WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION TRATA --
TALK ABOUT THEIR APPEALS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT COMMITMENT.
WE'LL BE SUPPORTING YOU BUILD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CAN BE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS CHAIRMAN
OF FIRST OF ALL WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR ON BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD --
AND I SHARE THE SAME --
SENTIMENTS EXACTLY THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE EXPRESSED I FOR
ONE HAD OPPORTUNITY BLESSED
OPPORTUNITY GO INTO DUBLIN --
WITH MISTER BRODER MISTER MULLIN
AND OTHER.
IN THAT SAME ROOM IN WHICH
FAMILIES POUR OUT THEIR HEART
ABOUT THEIR LOVED ONES --
BEING TAKEN AWAY FAR TOO SOON.
AND JUST LIKE MY COLLEAGUES AS
INDICATED WE PLEDGE TO DO
SOMETHING --
IT WHENEVER IT WILL BREAK IT
THOSE LOW ONCE BACK WE HOPE THAT
IT WILL PREVENT FUTURE
SITUATIONS FROM TAKING PLACE --
AND I WANNA GET IS COMMAND THE
AUTHOR --
FOR ONE HIS WILLINGNESS TO WORK
DILIGENTLY WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO MAKE THIS BILL BETTER.
I THINK IT'S MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION --
AND I HAPPEN TO KNOW YOU TO BE A
MAN OF YOUR WORD AND WE GAVE OUR
WORD IN DUBLIN. TO ALL THOSE
FAMILIES --
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN IN OUR
POWER TO MAKE IT BETTER.
AND SO I THINK THIS BILL HELPS
US GET. TO A POINT WHERE WE MAKE
IT BETTER AND WE ARE STANDING BY
OUR COMMITMENT IN TERMS OF THE
STATE AND PROTECTING THOSE WHO --
A NOW ONLY THOSE WHO LOST LIVES
ALSO PREVENTING THOSE FROM
ANYONE LOSING THEIR LIVES AS
WELL SO AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OBVIOUS WHERE THE BILL AS
WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CAN TO MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR HILL RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND ON
THE ISSUES RAISED THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR HILL
THIS DOES ENJOYING AYE
RECOMMENDATION.
AND THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SECTOR WHICH PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT LOW I'VE
LOW I'VE GROW.
GROW AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA.
BUT IN AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I OVERLOOKED IT.
ABILITY NOT VOTING TING.
THE BILL HAS TO A VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FRACTURE
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND IF YOU WOULD INDULGE ME I
HAVE TO VOTE IN --
UTILITIES IN THE SENATE AND THEN
I WILL COME BACK AND TAKE UP THE
NEXT BOOK BILLS AT YOUR AVERAGES
CHAIR HEALTH.
AND THE SERVICE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
CALL OUR OUR FOR OF FINAL AUTHOR
OTHER THAN SENATOR HILL WHICH IS
SENATOR LARA AND FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE S. B.. SIX NINETY
FIVE IN THE MEANTIME --
IF WE WILL THEN GO THROUGH THE
ROLE AGAIN.
AND WE WILL START --
WITHOUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
IT'S IT WE JUST WE JUST DEFINE
INTO SO WILL MOVE ON TO THAT --
SO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS S. B. EIGHT TWENTY NINE
SENATOR WIENER.
MOTIONS YOU PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND TAX
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER I CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MEDINA.
THE DEAN AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN I BIGGER FROM I DO NOT
VOTING.
AND THE BILL S. HAS ELEVEN VOTES
IN THE AND IS FILE ITEM THREE SB
EIGHT TWENTY NINE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
S. B..
NINE ZERO FOUR QUESTION IS
DEPOSITED JUDICIARY ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS FOURTEEN VOTES
BELIEVE THAT WILL OPEN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER [inaudible] SIX
S. B. TEN NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR CANNELLA.
MOTIONS TO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CHAU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING.
THE BILL HAS A FORTUNE VOTES
WHEN KNOW --
MOVE ON TO FILE UNDER ONE
BECAUSE WE HAD THE PRESENCE OF
AND AUTHOR WHICH IS S. B. SIX
NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR LARA
WELCOME SIMILAR PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
S. B. NINE SIX FIVE REMOVES
BARRIERS TO LICENSURE FOR
TEACHERS HEALTHCARE
PRACTITIONERS BY ALLOWING THE
USE OF AN INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER.
OR ITIN WHEN APPLYING FOR A
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE.
THE BILL CODIFIES INTO EXISTING
LAW THE COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING ITS CURRENT
PRACTICE OF USING A SUCH
SECURITY OR NIGHT TEN WHEN
APPLYING FOR A TEACHING
CREDENTIAL.
THE USE OF AND I TEND WHEN
APPLYING FOR A TEACHER WHO
ENJOYS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
ALLOWING OUR IMMIGRANT
POPULATION TO APPLY TO TEACH IN
THE STATE.
COUNTY CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCING
A MASSIVE TEACHER SHORTAGE
ESPECIALLY IN CERTAIN AREAS SUCH
AS BILINGUAL EDUCATION THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT EXPERIENCE
IMMIGRANT TEACHERS INCLUDING THE
ESTIMATED FIVE THOUSAND TEACHERS
WITH DOCTOR STATUS.
CAN CONTINUE TO TEACH IN THE
STATE.
UNLIKE THE CTC THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOPE. THIRTY CURRENTLY DID NOT
ALLOW IMMIGRANTS WITHOUT A
SECURITY TO APPLY FOR MANY
LICENSES AND CERTIFICATES
CERTIFICATES IN THEIR PURVIEW
THIS BILL MAKES A SMALL
TECHNICAL CHANGE IN THE CODE.
IN ORDER TO ALLOW IMMIGRANTS TO
APPLY FOR MANY OF THE LICENSES
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE BILL ALSO EXPANDS
OPPORTUNITIES TO MANY MORE
PROFESSIONS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING SHORTAGES INCLUDING
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANTS AND
HOME HEALTH AIDE THE USE OF IT I
TEND WHEN APPLYING FOR A LICENSE
PROVIDES.
THE SAME STANDARD OF INFORMATION
TO LICENSING ENTITIES WITHIN THE
HEALTH CARE SPHERE ENTITIES CAN
CHECK A GOOD MORAL CHARACTER OF
AN APPLICANT AS WELL AS A TAX
COMPLIANCE.
THROUGH THE I TEN CURRENTLY
DOCTORS DENTISTS AND REGISTERED
NURSES CAN ALL BE LICENSE USING
THEM I TEN BUT OTHER HEALTH
PRACTITIONERS WHO DO SIMILAR
WORK CANNOT.
A QUALIFIED PERSON WITH THE
CAREER ASPIRATIONS OF BECOMING A
TEACHER A NURSE ASSISTANT OR
PARAMEDIC SHOULD NOT BE BARRED
FROM --
BEING CREDENTIALED SIMPLY DUE TO
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE OF
ACCEPTANCE AND INTEGRATION AND
WE HAVE PROVEN TO DO SO AND SO
MANY OTHER LICENSES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I PUT.
THIS IN A BUSH ADVISER MIKE
GIPSON SAID YOU BY SOMEWHERE
MEDINA PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRISON WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
NO MORE MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
ARTIST RESPONSIBLE CHILL OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS I JUST WANT TO ECHO SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT THE CENTERS
ARE YOU MADE.
THAT THIS WAS THAT WE HAVE A
GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT NOW FOR
THOSE THAT ARE CURRENT
PROFESSIONAL LETTER DOCTOR
RECIPIENTS TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER BUT
UNFORTUNATELY.
BECAUSE THE POLITICAL CLIMATE WE
KNOW THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
FUTURE FOR THOSE ARE INDIVIDUALS
ARE THEREFORE I PASSING THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD ENSURE THAT
THEY'D BE ABLE TO CONTINUE. TO
BE LICENSED IN THEIR FIELD AFTER
THEY'VE BEEN TRAINED AND SO
THEREFORE WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
DISTURBANCES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SEEM DONE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SING AWARENESS IS
AN OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THE TIME.
TINA QUESTIONS COMMENTS SENATOR
LAURA DO WISH TO CLOSE THANK YOU
PROFESSOR I THINK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS PART OF EMOTION IS SECOND
COMMITTEES TERRY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
RUSSIA'S DE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I KNOW I
BROWN. FOR NOT PUTTING ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
LOW AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG NOT MONNING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I WON'T OPEN OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE NOW [inaudible]
TING.
THAT A BILL A HAS EIGHT VOTES
EMILY THE ROLE OPEN FOR AFTER
NUMBER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND ARE.
NOW BACK TO SENATOR HILL.
AS THE SENATE HERE WHAT IS YOUR
PLEASURE ON WHATEVER YOUR
PLEASURES MISTER CHAIR OKAY
ABOUT A PRESTIGIOUS FILE A ORDER
IT THAT HIM HE WAS ABSOLUTELY
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN WHICH IS S.
B..
THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN THIS DOES
ENJOY AND I I SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION FEEL VERY
DETERMINE EVERY RED.
THANK YOU RESPECT REACTION AYE
VOTE MEMBERS THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL VERY SIMPLE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY AND IT
WOULD ASSIST WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
CAN RED CROSS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SCENE THAN ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COULD MEMBERS.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THERE'S
BEEN IN MOTION AND A SECOND.
ALCHEMY SECURE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY LOW I'VE LOW EYEBROWS.
BROUGH AYE ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I FALL.
FONG I GIPSON.
IT'S AN AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
I WANT TO KNOW.
TING.
THE BILL HAS NINE OF VOTES IN
SUPPORT AND WILL LEAVE THE ROAD
OPEN FOR OPTIMUM THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN WHICH IS S. B. FOURTEEN
IT.
VERY S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY IS A
SUNSET CLEAN UP AND TECHNICAL
REVISION BILL WHICH INCLUDES
SEVERAL CHANGES TO THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD THE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AMONG OTHERS IN ADDITION
THIS BILL PROVIDES REGULATORY
FEE REVISIONS FOR THE BOARD OF
CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERS BORDER
PODIATRIC MEDICINE THE BOARD OF
RICHARD NURSING.
THE BOARD OF OCCASIONAL MESHING
IN PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS IN
THE NATURAL PATH THAT MEDICINE
COMMITTEE.
THE FEES PROPOSED BY THIS BILL
ARE THE RESULT OF MULTI YOUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE BOARD THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE OVER TO
STRANGERS THE CHANGES IN THIS
BILL ARE THE RESULT OF
DISCUSSIONS AND ISSUES RAISED
DURING PRIOR YEAR SINCE IT
REVIEWS.
AT THIS TIME THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION OF OPPOSITION SHOULD
ARISE THESE PROVISIONS WILL BE
REMOVED EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS IN
THE ANALYSIS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND TO A BY
SUMMER MEDINA AYE ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE FEEL FREE ONE EVERYBODY.
HI REBECCA MITCHELL WITH THE AND
THAT'S ABOUT THAT MEDICINE
COMMITTEE --
THE COMMITTEE IS IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY I WOULD
BELIEVE THAT DOES TO INCLUDE THE
CATEGORY ALLEGATIONS OF SERIOUS
HARM TO A MINOR --
IS URGENT WE AND KEPT IN THERE
I'M WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
REVISED FEE STRUCTURE IS
PROVIDED BY S. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ARE NECESSARY TO ASSIST
THE REGULATORY PROGRAMS.
INTO FILLING OUR PRIMARY DUTIES
OF CONSUMER PROTECTION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ROBERT POLITO WITH
THE BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC
EXAMINERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THIS WEEK BILL WOULD REVISE.
ALL FEES CHARGED BY THE BOARD OF
CHIROPRACTIC EXAMINERSBASED ON
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
COMPREHENSIVE FEE AUDIT THAT WAS
CONDUCTED LAST YEAR.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
I EITHER MATHIS WHEN OUR MEDICAL
BOARD HE WAS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL I'M HERE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE FOR US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT NAY
MANIPULATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO PLEASE FEEL FREE. FOR CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SOLOMON STILL I REPRESENT THE
LEVY ME SHUT THE FOR PET
PROTECTION.
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
PART OF THESE BEALE ABOUT
DISCLOSING PHARMACEUTICAL
INFORMATION TO CONSUMERS.
BECAUSE OF THESE WILL PROVIDE
NECESSARY PROTECTION TO
LITERALLY MILLIONS OF CONSUMERS
FROM CALIFORNIA.
WHO LOVE THEIR PETS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH?
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATHLEEN
COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
PODIA TOOK MEDICINE THANK YOU
SENATOR HELL.
SOMEONE IN LOVE WORK WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M VICKY LYMAN THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE
BOARD VOCATIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
SENATOR HILL.
MY DILLON CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROVISIONS RELATING TO
VETERINARY MEDICINE.
OUR TOP KAREN CALIFORNIA STATE
BOARD OF OPTOMETRY --
AS IT REFLECTS TECHNICAL CHANGES
THAT ASSIST IN THE BOARD'S
OPERATION WE JUST WANT --
TO THANK BECAUSE SENATOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING HER OUT
WITH THAT THANK YOU.
KATHY BERG WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND I HEAR TO EXPRESS
A FORMAL POSITION JUST TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSING FEES.
AND EXPRESSWAYS TO WORK EVEN
FURTHER NEXT YEAR THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY.
OPENNESS IS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION FOOD PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO COME UP TO THE PODIUM HERE.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
MR SHARE MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES --
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BASED ON THE MINUTES THAT WERE
TAKEN LAST WEEK WHEN WE LEARNED
OF THE AMENDMENTS TO OUR CAMP
TECH THAT CATHERINE SUCH THERE
BE COUNCIL.
ON THURSDAY OR FRIDAY OF LAST
WEEK ON THE BILL ISN'T RIGHT NOW
DELETE OUT THE REQUIREMENT FOR
THEM TO TAKE AN EXAMINATION IN
ORDER.
TO YOU KNOW ENSURE THAT THERE'S
COMPETENCY TO UP RACKS ARE
COMMUNITIES.
WE THINK THAT THAT IS A HIGHLY
INAPPROPRIATE AND THERE'S SOME
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS IN HERE.
THAT SUGGESTS THAT PERHAPS WOULD
BE SUSPENDED I'M WE STILL THINK
THAT YOU DON'T NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THESE FOLKS ARE --
LICENSE TO PROPERLY OR CERTIFIED.
AND THERE'S REALLY NO WAY. TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE WITHOUT
THAT EXAMINATION ON THERE WAS A
MULTIPLE OUR SPECIAL HEARING A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO REGARDING KIM
TACK IN THE SCHOOLS.
THIS ISSUE WAS NOT BROUGHT UP
THEN --
EXCUSE ME WAS NOT BROUGHT OF
THEN A MOTHER THAN AS A SIDE
COMMENT ABOUT SOME PARTICULAR
STUDENTS.
I'M SO WE FEEL THAT IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE INCLUDED IN AND THIS
MEASURE NOW WE CERTAINLY LIKE TO
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION CAN A
MOVING FORWARD --
BUT THE CERTIFICATION SHOULD
REQUIRED EXAMINATION THANK YOU.
DID YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
PLEASE [inaudible]
YEAH.
HI MY NAME IS SONYA AWAY AND
WITH THE FEDERATION OF STATE
MASSAGE THERAPY BOARDS.
I APOLOGIZE A LITTLE TALLER THAN
I AM AND I'M PROVIDING THIS
COMMENT ON BEHALF OF AND HOLDEN
WHO IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
FEDERATION AND HE AND PARTIALLY
WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE IT THIS
MORNING DUE TO TRAVEL DELAYS.
WE OUR SPECIFICALLY --
OPPOSING SECTION TWENTY ONE OF
THIS BILL RELATING TO REMOVING
THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
LICENSING EXAM --
THEY FEDERATION IS ACTUALLY AT
THAT COMPOSED AND THAT COVERED
BY STATE BOARDS OF MASSAGE
THERAPY AYE WE A FORTY FIVE
MEMBER PORTS AND AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA MASSAGE
THERAPY COUNCIL --
AND THE BOARDS ARE ABLE TO
INFLUENCE AND VOTE UPON POLICIES
THAT PERTAIN TO THE EXAM --
THE EXAM WAS SPECIFICALLY
DEVELOPED TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF THE REGULATORY COMMUNITY IT'S
AN ENTRY LEVEL EXAMINATION WITH
MORE THAN A THIRD OF ITS CONTENT
BUT IT'S THE TOPICS.
OF ETHICS AND PROFESSIONAL
PRACTICE AND THERE ARE AYE IF
YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE STATE
THEIR FORTY FOUR STATES THAT
REQUIRE THE MASSAGE AND BODYWORK
LICENSING EXAM.
PLUS THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
PRETTY RICO AND THE U. S. VIRGIN
ISLANDS.
WE I HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS
THAT -- THAT
THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S SEEING AND HOPE TO
CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEN ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THREE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SENIOR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME.
SENATE HAVE DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE
I I DO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT THE
QUESTION IS YOU KNOW THE
AMENDMENT WAS PLACED IN HERE
BECAUSE OF THE OF THE FEDERATION
OF MASSAGE THERAPY PORRIDGE IN
THE SCHOOL WAS NOT ALLOWING --
CMT SEE SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
APPROVED TO BE SUBJECT TO THE
TEST.
BECAUSE OF THAT THESE ARE ALL
THIS ONLY APPLIES TO SCHOOLS
THAT ARE BEING INVESTIGATED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE OF A
STANDARD THAT WOULD.
WOULD THEN QUALIFY FOR BEING
CERTIFIED.
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
TESTING WE FOUND THAT THE THE
PROCESS THAT THE THAT COUNCIL
GOES THROUGH RIGHT NOW IN THE
SUBJECTIVE OVER THE THE
OBJECTIVE MANNER IN WHICH THEY
THEY DO THEIR OWN EVALUATION
TEST TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT A HALF APPLIED
FOR CERTIFICATION HAVE GONE. TO
A NON CERTIFIED SCHOOL THAT IS
PENDING CERTIFICATION OR NOT AT
THIS POINT DOES HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE TESTED WITHIN
THE ORGANIZATION AND CHECKED AND
EVALUATED TO MAKE SURE THEY GOT
THE EDUCATION.
IS NECESSARY AND THAT THEY HAVE
A LEGITIMATE EDUCATION FROM THE
SCHOOL SO THERE'S NOT IS IF
THERE'S NO TESTING GOING ON
THERE'S JUST NO.
UP A TEST THAT WAS USED AS PART
OF A TOTAL EVALUATION THE REST
OF THE EVALUATION IS GOING ON IN
THE GOAL IS THE SAME HERE AS IT
WAS BEFORE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE.
QUALIFIED CREDIBLE AND THE
APPROPRIATE MASSAGE THERAPISTS
PRACTICING IN CALIFORNIA AND NO
ONE WANTS TO GO BACK TO THE
SITUATION WE HAD OF YOUR AGO.
WHERE WE HAD THE --
THE CHALLENGES IN THE PROBLEMS
OF OF MASSAGE THERAPY IN
CALIFORNIA THIS DOES NOT TAKE US
THERE WITH THIS BILL THAT.
SURE THANK YOUR RESPECT WE HAVE
TRIBAL MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I HOPE THIS DOESN'T
CHOI IN AYE RECOMMENDATION
THAT'S BEEN IN MOTION AND SECOND
COMMITTEE SICK DAY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS LOW AYE LOW AYE BRO.
BROWNOUT ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BIGGER NOT VOTING [inaudible]
BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN?
CHEN NOT VOTING JOKE.
CHIU AYE COMING OUT.
COMING UP NOT VOTING EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FALL.
PHONE UP VOTING GIPSON.
GIVES AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE.
AND MORE THAN I TING
[inaudible]
THING I AT PRESENT I AM IT GOT
S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY MOTIONS DO
PASS AS A MINUTE OPERATIONS
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE.
THAT OF BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
AND BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN TRAPS
MEMBERS AND FINALLY WE GO ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN WHICH
IS S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
WHICH ALSO ENJOYS IN IRAQ.
AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION VERY GOOD
THANK YOU S. B. FOURTEEN ANYONE
IS A SENSE THAT BILL FOR THE
STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL BOARD.
THIS BILL MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES
TO THE STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL
BURKE INTENDED TO IMPROVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AFFECT YOU
ASTRONOMICAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
ADDRESS WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
AND CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND KENNY
I MEAN THIS IS A SAILOR I'M THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL BOARD --
A COURSE IN SUPPORT RESIDENTS
THAT BUILDING EXTENDED.
AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THAT YOU
VERY MUCH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE ARE PART BEHALF OF
THE PEST CONTROL OPERATORS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THEY GIVE A MUCH IN ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEE NO
WOULD SUPPORT ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HE
NOTICES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS A COMES FROM
COULD BE MEMBERS THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND COMMITTEE
SEXUALLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH'S DE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENT SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS SLOW I KNOW
I BROWN.
WELL I ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
WHEN I CHEN?
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS SIXTY VOTES BELIEVE
THE RULE OF AND I'M VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MEMBERS THINK YOU'VE
[inaudible]
SHE JILL DO YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
BILLS HERE. FOURTEEN NINETY ONE
AND NINETY TWO ONLY THOSE WHO
ARE THE AYE CONCERTS AND I DID
NOT KNOW THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
BUT YOU LIKE YOUR MOTHER HOGAN
SAYS THAT IF YOU WISH YOU ARE
WONDERFUL THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MEMBERS BRIGHT LIGHT
APPROACHES.
A MEMBERS WILL NOW GO THROUGH
FILE ITEM AND BEGINNING WITH --
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEMS ON CONSENT CALENDAR AB
NINE TWENTY IT BEFORE TO NINETY
ONE A. B. FOURTEEN AYE DETAIL
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CHIU. TO AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
WHEN I TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
IT IS.
ZERO WAS OUT.
AND THEN MOVING IN FILE ORDER
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE BEGIN WITH SP.
SIX NINETY FIVE MOTIONS DID
PASTOR PREPARATIONS ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible] TO CHIU AYE.
THIRTEEN TO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE MOTIONS YOU
PASS AS AMENDED TO COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM NOW [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
OBERNOLTE.
ABILITY NOW TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. FOURTEEN TO DO THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB.
EIGHT TWENTY NINE MUCH HAS DID
PASS THE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
AND TAX ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I FALL [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. THIRTEEN THE
ONE THE BILL IS OUT FIGHTING
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP.
NINE ZERO FOUR MOTIONS DAY
PASSED TO JUDICIARY ARAMBULA.
CHU.
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. SEVEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B..
TEN NINETY EIGHT MOTION IS DAY
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
JILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. SEVENTEEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN S. B..
TWELVE FIFTY FOUR MOTIONS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH ARAMBULA [inaudible]
JILL.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. SIXTEEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT S.
B..
THIRTEEN OH FIVE MOTIONS DE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO JUDGE IT
JUDICIARY ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE
. SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE S. B..
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE HOLDEN
[inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. SEVENTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
WHICH IS.
AT S. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN MOTIONS DO
PASSED TO JUDICIARY ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
JILL.
CHIU AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE. FOURTEEN WHEN THE BILL
IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
WHICH IS S. B..
FOURTEEN FORTY TWO MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED HER PREPARATIONS
BRO [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE GIPSON [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE NOTING [inaudible]
TING AYE. FIFTEEN TO ONE THE
BILL IS OUT.
FILE AND A NUMBER.
TWELVE S. B..
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS BRO
[inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE GIPSON
[inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOTING [inaudible]
TING AYE. FIFTEEN THE ONE THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY MUSTN'T MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I SO THE ONE THE BILL IS
OUT AND FILED UNDER FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE MOTIONS DID
PASS THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENT SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS ARAMBULA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I SEVENTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT
.
MS FOR A FILE ITEM NUMBER. SEVEN
WHICH IS S. B. TWELVE FIFTY FOR
THE VOTE TOTAL THE FINAL IS.
SEVENTEEN OH AND THE BILL IS OUT.
I WAS THAT CONCLUDES --
THE FILES ANY ADDITIONAL ITEMS
.
AS WE SIX NINE FIVE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED YOUR PREPARATIONS.
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
.
S. B. SEVEN TWENTY ONE MOTIONS
DO PASS AS AMENDED COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE. FIFTEEN TO TWO
BILLS OUT
MEMBERS WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MINUTE